hey guys Pete here
today we're here to talk about Better
Call Saul season 6 episode 11.
Breaking Bad not to be uh confused with
the the uh Breaking Bad episode Better
Call Saul
we did get our big Return of the main
characters of that show which was fun to
watch and added some things to the main
character here's story Jimmy McGill AKA
Saul Goodman AKA Gene takovic
it was a I I enjoyed this episode
um it's been keeping up with this trend
of being satisfied you know being
satisfying in a strange way you know not
exactly what I'm I'm hoping for when I
go into it but um always kind of
surprised at what they come up with and
how
how interesting things are like how
they're approaching this and not knowing
what's going to happen next it's all
pretty exciting
I have asked some of my friends to come
here and talk about that today and I'll
let them introduce themselves in a
second
um
they'll give us their overview of what
they thought about the episode now that
they had a day or a sleep to let it
um you know sink in
and then I'll come back around we'll
talk about that we'll answer your
questions and we'll hit on some other
points we want to talk about so Gil why
don't you introduce yourself and let me
know what you thought of the episode
sure thing thanks for having me on Pete
I'm Gil from the YouTube channel one
take and the podcast sawcast I love the
episode I really really love the episode
even putting aside the breaking bad
stuff just the gene of it all they got
us to essentially watch an addict spiral
hard into a relapse I think that's
essentially what we were seeing with
Gene
um but they got us to not want to look
away from it because a it's another fun
scheme it's another fun montage and they
somehow still kept me hoping that maybe
Gene wouldn't go too far you know for
example toward the end of the episode
you get to that big moment where he
finds out that the latest Mark has
cancer and it definitely hits him and it
least I was hoping okay maybe he'll see
this is a step too far his conscience is
still there and he'll walk away but of
course he doesn't so it was uh very
tragic and sad episode which seems to be
the trend lately I think it was nice
that we had nippy right before this get
a little bit of a breather so it was it
was a tough episode but there was enough
there to to not make us just look away
from the awfulness and then the breaking
bad stuff we've been wondering for so
long how do you revisit the Breaking Bad
timeline without it just being for fan
service and for me it did two important
things one
it showed us the Breaking Bad timeline
from Saul Goodman's perspective and how
he thinks of it at least at the moment
as Gene and as Gene he's based off of
the particular moments he pulled out and
that we saw his flashbacks it seems that
he sees himself as a pretty important
piece of pulling Walt up from the minor
leagues and introducing him to Gus
advocating for him when Mike said that
he shouldn't so he thinks of himself I
think as larger responsible for a lot of
what happened in the Breaking Bad
timeline uh which makes it all the more
impactful when we see that he is
repeating the same mistakes he's doing
the exact same thing again it makes it
very clear that Jimmy is stuck in this
awful pattern he's repeating it and
that's why I think it's such a hard
episode to watch and and they used the
Breaking Bad timeline and the fact that
that show is so important to us they use
that to make that hit even harder so
it's a great episode for me
cool and Courtney you want to introduce
yourself
sure hey guys I'm Courtney from
Courtney's reviews uh all I've talked
about so far on my channel is Better
Call Saul I just started it back in
March so do analysis and sometimes
prediction and Theory videos although
I've stopped doing that because I just
find it like I can't I can't really
every idea I've had a couple of them
have been confirmed but they just keep
throwing curveballs and it's it's so
much fun just to see where where they're
taking us on on this ride and um I I
share some of your sentiments uh Gil I
really liked this episode at first when
I was first watching it I was like with
the cold open and the breaking bad I was
like okay so we're seeing it from his
perspective and I had originally like
imagined that we would get something we
hadn't seen before and of course it is
from his point of view so I was a little
but as the episode went on I could see
how it worked thematically to give
context to what was going on with Jean
because apart from that um the five
minutes we got from the previous episode
where we see him on his rotating bed and
going about is yeah we don't really get
to see Saul and Saul is really the
monster isn't he so this was I think a
good reminder of what happened in that
Gap that we weren't shown just reminding
us like what what Saul Goodman actually
did I mean the Howard thing aside right
in that scheme and how awful that was he
went on to commit far worse offenses
right
um throughout uh Breaking Bad and um I
have a lot of thoughts about this one
I'm still in the process of working on
my my breakdown I'm a little slower than
everyone else so just wrapped up a
semester getting grades in answering
Panic student emails stuff like that so
you know it's been keeping me busy but
um I tend to to think very literally
that's kind of my wheelhouse and I keep
thinking I'll give you guys a little
spoiler about what my thesis is in my
breakdown analysis is this is the story
of Frankenstein and Frankenstein is this
octoxin on this being that is made up of
parts of other men and that's how I see
this character so he's a little little
bit Jimmy he's a little bit saw a little
bit Gene but he's also as this creature
something new and we got quite a few
Frankenstein references throughout the
the episode and just as a quick little
reminder what is Frankenstein's first
name
Victor so yeah so um you guys will see
that on my uh my breakdown I'll go into
it pretty deep into it but yeah I
enjoyed it I enjoyed it a lot the Victor
with a K by the way
Maybe no it's with the c I'm pretty sure
yeah I'm not sure either but uh I like
the idea that it's with the k
yeah and um that that's a great that's
that kind of
um
that kind of leads into what I wanted to
start out with but just to just to kind
of talk about some of what you're saying
there I I do agree Gil uh you know we're
watching this cycle
um like the addiction cycle the relapse
and that was my big question at the end
of the last episode because it seemed
kind of like
he was getting off scot-free and and
that would be a bad thing for an addict
to have happen because you know if you
if you get away with doing the thing
you're not supposed to do then
you're more likely to do it again right
I mean if there's no consequences then
why the hell not and it you know so I I
was I was I was pretty focused in on
that at the end of the last episode of
like well this is the worst thing that
could have happened to him yeah he
pulled it off
but now you know how does he put the you
know how does he how does he walk away
from that we saw that he was he was you
know instantly lifted up he was a
different you know version of Gene that
we hadn't seen before in that you know
he's smiling at work and
he seems a lot more uh Lively and um I
was glad that they hit that right away
here and
like you said
um you know there's
it it went it's a circle it's a cycle
and
whenever he whenever he um
whenever he does this you know it's in
it's in reaction to to this pain that he
hasn't ever dealt with and
at the end of this even though it was a
downer it you know it's like well what
do they do what are they actually
setting up here are they setting it up
for him to go down
you know
hard like you know uh Walter White did
because I thought there was you know
there were so many parallels that you
started to have to consider that in a
way that I hadn't before
but then also you know like are they
setting it up for
him to make a turn which is really hard
to to imagine like where he's at at the
end you know so seeing him sort of go on
the slippery slope and just escalate all
the way I mean they were like adding
different components as they went you
know what I mean like put on he had he
put on the pinky ring last week it was
kind of fun
and you know like you said I think we
needed that for just to as a reminder of
who he is and or or more of an
explanation I guess of who he is in that
timeline like what he did there was
necessary in order to make this feel
like the fall that it actually was and I
think you know what I really like the
idea that you have there um Courtney
about Frankenstein because
you know who who
one part of it is because Bob Odenkirk
is so good at playing all these
different
uh you know versions of of Jimmy McGill
so that they they're distinct and you
know
what are that what does that mean
whenever you have all these all these
parts you know what what is the hole
after you have the sum of all these
parts and it's a really fascinating
question I think
and so I guess you know you you guys
touched on this a little bit and this
was the first thing I wanted to to talk
about before we got into answering
questions and that was you know how
Mike's appearance
it's one of those things you know it's
like you know I thought there was a
perfect ending for Mike and I I didn't
think he needed to come back but of
course you know it's Mike so I want him
to come back
and it was a really it was a really
interesting thing where you know he's
saying hey stay away from this guy he's
an amateur he's Small Potatoes he
doesn't sound like he's on Gus's radar
yet you know I think maybe that's a
little bit debatable of like what he
would tell Saul but um
stay away
and you know we see that we see that
compulsion again you know it's sort of
like the switch back in in
season two where you know it's just the
only thing he has to do is not flip the
switch it's clear and he can't help
himself and that of course that's
Chuck's idea that we heard Howard say
just as recently as as 607 so you know
the whole idea the thing I wanted to ask
you guys was is how do you think this
re-contextualizes that relationship
between Saul and Walt
uh for for me I'd say I think I touched
on it earlier when I was getting my yeah
thoughts
um but essentially I think for us to
view Gene's actions this episode as a
repeating pattern they wanted to make
sure that we saw the events of Breaking
Bad through Saul's eyes and in his eyes
those events were a result of his choice
he was the one who advocated for Walter
so he made the choice he caused a lot of
the damage that occurred and now he's
making a similar Choice again so uh to
me so I guess how did it affect the
relationship between him and Walt for me
it was essentially showed us how he
viewed it where he was the advocate he
was the one I guess I'm starting to
repeat myself like Jimmy McGill but he's
the one who made that choice and now
he's making a similar Choice again
right and I think like you know I saw a
lot of people commenting that like
Saul made Walter White you know what I
mean and I and to me I think that that
kind of misses the point a little bit
like I I think what you're saying is a
lot more important it's what he thought
you know is what it's what it's what
Jimmy thinks about it and how he
internalizes that
um what do you think Courtney well I'm
I'm kind of in in the camp that it shows
his culpability and everything that that
happens right so like what happened to
him the horror of being kidnapped right
and then being carted to the desert in
the back of an RV and he's like you know
got a bag over his head and he's bound
up and then when he gets back on the RV
he's you know it's just opportunity
that's all he's seeing he sees dollar
signs and so um it just really speaks to
his really poor decision making and um I
think that scene with Mike is just to
reinforce that you know that this was a
really bad idea from from the get-go and
um again with the Frankenstein thing
that one of the first thing he says when
they get in the RV is he calls Jesse
Igor and then he says to Walt you must
be
um Heisenberg and I see some people in
the in the comments being like but you
know Frankenstein was the scientist not
not the monster yes I know that
um
I don't think it's a one for one here
and I actually and um I don't want to
take up too much much time talking about
this because this is all I've been
thinking about all day I think they're
all kind of Frankenstein type monsters
right so like you see like in the
characters of Mike Walt and Saul you
have these elements of different people
right so like you have Mr Chips and
Scarface
um with Mike uh you see
um you know like how he thinks of
himself as like the the loving
um grandfather and trying to do what
like he thinks he has a conscience you
know tries to do the right thing but
ultimately is just another gangster like
Nacho's father uh says to him so um and
then of course uh Saul is a little bit
of the the mad scientist himself right
so how he's able to
um put things together and and stuff
like that but of course he ends up
becoming a monster and I think that's
the big takeaway they all end up
becoming monsters in the end
yeah and that that's why I really like
the the fact that this is Mike and it's
set up this way because there is that
parallel you know he's telling he's
telling Saul something that he shouldn't
do and maybe he wouldn't do it himself
either you know maybe Mike would would
actually stay away from him but it's the
same kind of thing Papa Vargo was
telling him you know what you're doing
it's not Justice you're just a gangster
and you think you have this code that
you live by that's just your way of
basically lying to yourself to say hey
it's all right I'm different from these
guys when eventually he becomes the same
and you know those guys
some of them were probably pure uh
sociopaths or whatever but they probably
had a similar uh transformation you know
where they thought they had a reason to
do whatever they were doing in a moment
and it and it Spirals and it snowballs
and
that's kind of where they all end up so
yeah I think that that I think that's a
lot more interesting than
oh Saul Saul stepped in whenever you
know
nobody else wanted to work with Walton
and he made it happen because you know
Walter was was he he may have gotten
arrested he may have you know dropped
dropped off the radar some of them might
have killed him if it weren't for for
Saul but I I think it's more of just
like how these people come together
how they influence each other and how it
all kind of leads to the same place
and you know that that's not that that
really gave it a dark feeling coming out
of the end of this episode
yeah this was not a fun episode I I
didn't enjoy watching the the heists or
um the cons at all it was um it reminded
me a little bit of how like what what
they did with this character is similar
to how
um how Breaking Bad ends with Walt you
know by the end of it you know you
really really just see how how monsters
he is like the Ozymandias moment
yeah yeah I just go ahead I was just
going to uh Courtney just second when
you said it well you didn't enjoy
watching The Heist and when they were or
the schemes when they were doing that
montage and the music was so Melancholy
I started to feel myself get emotional
and it reminded me of watching I don't
know if either of you have seen Leaving
Las Vegas with Nicholas Cage where the
entire premise of that movie there isn't
I mean it's such a bleak movie it's
about a man who just goes and decides to
drink himself to death he knows he's
killing himself and that's kind of what
I felt like I was watching with Gene via
the imagery of uh Gene lying in the
grave Doug for Saul probably also put
that idea in my head but just the tone
of it and just seeing him doing the scam
even though I don't think he could
really tell you exactly why he's doing
it I don't think he needs the money he
doesn't look like he's enjoying it it's
just you can't look away but it's not
fun to watch
yeah and I think they did set up a
progression there the first guy almost
seemed like he had it coming to him you
know I mean he was he was pretty much an
ass he he was he was trying to con Jimmy
you know what I mean so or Gene so you
know it it it through that Montage it
started to get darker and darker and you
know you could you could see the
character you could see Bob Odenkirk you
know just getting more and more caught
up as it went on too and of course it it
all comes together whenever he he freaks
out on buddy but um yeah I thought in
the beginning I was like oh well this
isn't that bad you know what I mean and
you know pretty quickly you're like oh
this is terrible what is he doing you
know well and he's uh he's drugging
people which feels like of course he did
that with Howard but every scam up until
then he at least you could say he kind
of takes advantage of people's
attempting to do something they
shouldn't like with the watch scam back
in the day people were trying set people
up to try and screw him over and then he
screws them over but here he's just
completely taking away their their
choice you know he's knocking them out
and then taking advantage of them it's
like Hannibal Lecter only eating the
rude right right
all right so we have a bunch of super
chats thank you all for asking questions
we'll go through them here Marilyn
ailman thank you for the 499 I feel that
Breaking Bad title
feel that the Breaking Bad title has
more meaning than just our viewing of
Walt and Jesse Saul's downfall was Walt
the cancer patient will be genes I think
that they they definitely drew that
parallel with the way they cut those
scenes and we're supposed to think about
that and that's the question you know
that we're asking
will this cancer patient be his downfall
um I'm not 100 sure we got two full
episodes to go
I think that will probably go and spend
some time with Kim you know I I think
we'll find out the the conclusion of
this
in the next episode like what happens
when he goes inside that house
but I'm kind of thinking that we might
we might
things might be slower on that end if we
can actually squeeze in some Kim so what
do you guys think um
do you think that it will be his
downfall and then do you think that
we're gonna see
a pre because I mean the phone call
thing it seemed like because we don't
hear what what what she's saying to him
or what he's saying that that's a setup
similar to the nacho call earlier with
Mike and that we'll see it from we don't
know what's going on now but when we see
it from her perspective it'll all make
sense
you know uh so yeah do you think that
we'll see quite a bit of Kim in the next
episode or am I just is that just uh you
know we're still wishing yeah I think we
will and I hope we do
um I I expect to see Kim for sure and um
I hope we get to see her side of the
phone call as well as far as whether
this cancer patient will be his downfall
I think he's already headed down that
way so he's already spiraling and I
think this episode's set up a couple
different things that it raised a couple
different questions because he is
creating
um he's obviously he's thrown all
caution to the wind right he's not being
careful and there are a couple
possibilities right so like Kim could
say something she could tell the police
that he was contacted I'm not saying
that I think this is what it is going to
be I'm just saying like I think that
they raise these questions I think Buddy
is also perhaps a weakness certainly
Marion at the end when she's looking out
the window when she sees them going into
the garage she's very suspicious and I
think as I've said before I think she's
a lot sharper than
um maybe Gene thinks she is you know
might might be mistaking her for one of
his old clients that was easy to dupe um
I don't think that's the case with her
and uh so it and certainly Francesca as
well you know there are a couple
different possibilities for how he could
get in trouble but I actually think it's
going to be his own doing
um I don't know we'll have to wait and
see of course
yeah I think I seconded a lot of what
you just said Courtney I think the the
main point of him opening the door at
the end of the episode is to tell us
that we are essentially watching his
downfall in progress whether it's this
particular moment or it's going to be
the next thing but the point is that
he's being Reckless because buddy
everything he said made total sense
we're making good money we don't need
this guy and if he knew a little bit
more he might even realize Gene doesn't
need this money at all
so he's taking bigger risks he's being
Reckless so if this isn't the thing that
gets him something will get him when I
think about the fact that there's only
two episodes left it makes me think okay
maybe this will be the thing uh but if
it's not I think there's something else
right around the corner yeah I think
he's definitely on a path of
self-destruction this is self-sabotage
it's almost like I don't know if it's a
conscious thing but it's almost like he
wants to get caught at least that's how
I read it you know because why it takes
such a risk yeah I'd agree with that
it's self-destructive at the very least
I mean he can't he can't look at it and
be like wow my life is improving as I'm
doing all this stuff you know what I
mean he's definitely you know
he he isn't he isn't worried about you
know staying safe or or you know
anything he I'm sure you know in his
mind he justifies this all by saying no
I really have it planned out so nothing
will go wrong you know what I mean but
you know he's definitely like you said
Reckless is is at the very least
um
Richard Seymour thank you for the five
what if Kim told Jimmy Jean Saul that
she was cooperating with the police
um I mean I guess that's possible
uh I don't
I don't know how they I really don't
know how she would get on the radar
at this point in time what would she
know about the events they're interested
in right she wasn't as far as we know
she wasn't on the inside during Breaking
Bad so she wouldn't really know anything
that wasn't public at least I wouldn't
expect that
yeah a couple of interesting points so
uh you I I meant to hit on what you were
saying about him not caring about the
money I mean I think that that him
talking to I know Tom Schnell said this
in interviews as well but that point
where where he doesn't even consider
what Buddy's saying that he's just full
compulsion you know it does show that
it's not about the money at all it's
about what he's experiencing internally
as a result of that phone call and um
you know the other thing is
that it's interesting that when he makes
the phone call
he knows where he thinks she works you
know what I mean so I I don't know if
that's an indication that they've seen
each other since
um 609 you know what I mean like did she
come to Albuquerque
during the Breaking Bad timeline and
they saw each other and that's where he
got the idea that she was in Florida or
is it something else you know
yeah this was a question I was wondering
like uh how did he know she was in
Florida did she tell him herself that
she was moving there because he um he
knew that she was in Titusville and that
she worked at some sort of sprinkler
store the street story about the fish's
name she knew all that so I was
wondering if that's something like maybe
they stayed in touch at some point or if
maybe the scene with Mike was meant as a
reminder to us that he was Saul's pi and
maybe you know he was able to track her
down for him
I don't know you might all you know I
was thinking about this today too where
uh if Francesca even makes the comment
to Gene she's like don't you have the
internet like why are you asking me
about all these people it might not even
be that hard to track her down I mean I
don't know how much of a social media
presence she would want to have but I
kept reminding myself it's 2010 we see
the YouTube cat videos it might not be
that hard to find out where she lives uh
even if they're not keeping in touch
yeah I thought that was funny because I
I just kind of think of Better Call Saul
as a you know a no internet kind of
world you know what I mean it's pretty
analog and then we did have Marion
um watching YouTube which is it felt
kind of out of place in a way
yeah Gian taurones uh thank you for the
10. I'm one of those who have been
disappointed lately I guess partly
because I'm rooting for Jimmy to redeem
himself and it's crushing to see him
continue to go back to his old ways it
yeah I I would agree with this sentiment
I wouldn't say that I've been
disappointed because
I you know I I think that they have a
reason
to to go in this direction that will be
you know that'll make sense at least as
far as being a good story at the end you
know it may mean that that Jimmy is uh
not who you know who doesn't end up
being the person that I was hoping he
would be at the end the character that
he would be at the end but
um I I think it'll be in service of a
good story The the thing that I I did
kind of pick up on I think you know in
reading the interviews is
they they kind of are the way they talk
about him it's not they're not very
um
they don't look at him as as fondly as
they used to it seems like after writing
this this uh this process I don't know
if it's about writing the ending of it
and ending the series or if it's just
what he's going through right now
but it it doesn't seem like they have
you know much sympathy for what's going
on with them they're they're kind of
angry almost it feels like or at least
uh Peter gold and and Tom Tom schnall's
snails both sort of sound that way in
recent interviews
kind of like when Frankenstein built his
monster and it turned on him
nice
uh Roger Rubio thank you for the ten
dollars another great episode I'm still
a bit confused I thought in season four
Saul tells friend chesca tell him Jimmy
sent you I feel a little confused on
that end yeah he gives her a card first
and he says what are you gonna tell the
police and she says talk to my lawyer
and he gives her a card
and that's when he says tell him Jimmy
sent you on the as far as the phone call
he says where are you going to be at
that time
and um
and she says I'll be there but if it
doesn't ring I'm leaving and he says
it'll ring so he you know it all fits in
with what what their conversation was
it's interesting because you know this
was the idea was is that was going to be
Kim
were you guys let down by the fact as I
I know that fans sort of figured this
out in the last couple of weeks okay the
the popularity of the theory that that
was really going to be Jimmy calling
Francesca
you know came up a lot over the last
couple of weeks were you disappointed to
see that that's what this was or
you know where you where you were you
just thinking that was just fine
I wasn't disappointed certainly after
609 and seeing the um the breakup I had
a feeling it wasn't going to be Kim
calling and then as far as the question
of the lawyer I know there's like a lot
of people have many questions about how
did X Y or Z happen how did he get the
diamonds how did the office get fixed
and I um was trying to manage
expectations I don't think we're gonna
see a lot of that I mean maybe some of
it like it might come up like maybe
they'll show us the diamonds didn't he
mention like a jeweler
like a client that was or a client that
was yeah jewelry in this most recent
episode something like that yeah yeah
yeah when he was talking to Mike he said
something about a jeweler you know who
knows
um so yeah no I wasn't terribly
disappointed about that
yeah foreign
thank you for the 4.99 while we see Kim
ever again I think we're all the
consensus is yes we will
do you think Jimmy Saul and Dean dies in
the end I hadn't thought that and I I
still don't really think that but I
think I think right now they're telling
us that maybe we should be worried about
it I think they want us to think that
that might happen at the very least what
do you guys think
uh I'm at least what you just said
basically I wasn't worried about it it
just felt like just because a show is
ending it doesn't mean that the
character has to die right there are so
many other ways to conclude a story but
it feels like in this violent world of
Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul even
when we see Gene the stakes have not
been at a level where I'm worried
anything lethal is going to happen it's
just natural to wonder about that but I
would say after this episode I am
worried about it because it does feel
like he's going just
he's gonna just keep going down he's
that doesn't seem like he's going to uh
learn that he shouldn't be conning
people uh it feels like he's gonna keep
going until he hits Rock Bottom which
sometimes means death you know it could
be as simple as he scams the wrong guy
they get pissed off and they shoot him
you know you just it feels like if he
continues this way death is the just
ultimate conclusion doesn't mean it'll
go that way but if nothing changes it
feels like that's the inevitable end
yeah I agree I think there there is
still possibility for him to change to
turn things around I think something
might happen like like theoretically
cancer patient dies and maybe you know
because it's from the barbiturates some
sort of counteraction with his
medications something serious Could
Happen
um there that could make him take pause
and you know give himself up
um maybe he's convinced by someone to
turn himself in
um and I think the only person that
would actually be able to do that would
be Kim
um and I imagine that's probably how
that conversation went that's just my
head Canon of how it went though so I
don't know I think there's still
possibility for not not maybe Redemption
but for him to change I don't think
they're going to kill him they might I
just I feel like that would be too
breaking bad for him to die at the end
you know so I think they're gonna
they're definitely playing with their
expectations though we should be
concerned about him because what he is
doing is deeply concerning
yeah man like and I you know just to
reiterate what I said a minute ago
totally agree they want us to be worried
about that you know they're definitely
playing with our expectations on that
and um
I do also agree that you know Kim is the
only thing that like he is in the grip
of addiction if we're looking at it just
through that lens and you know he
something is going to have to
push him in the direction of of changing
you know I mean he's if if left alone
left to his own devices he'll just
escalate you know he'll just progress
further along into that so
um you know it's hard to look around and
see anybody else in this universe
besides Kim that can make that happen
it's just that you know the this call we
as far as we can tell it made him worse
rather than better
Mikey thank you for the five dollars
Canadian two weeks ago I guess color
timeline was around season two episode
nine of Breaking Bad based on the public
masturbation line two of you said
I was wrong turns out I guessed right
um
yeah but that's not really correct yeah
I disagree the other scene the other
scene was definitely prior to this
um we've seen two two different periods
in that I mean they they said that I
mean it's not just me talking like it's
that's what they said it was
either 2005 or 2007 before he met these
guys so we did jump forward a little bit
here but you know it
congrats on
getting that they did get to that point
in time I guess
um all right let's see
formula
four fours and four eights
thank you for the 4.99 again it's a
really difficult name to read just in
case you were wondering glad you're all
back wondered what happened on the
Saturday night stream
yeah I I
um
Saturday I had planned on doing that I
had a lot of other stuff going on
Courtney was supposed to come and she
was busy and had to back out and I just
I I didn't make an uh announcement or
anything because I was hoping to still
do it even if I had to do it by myself
but uh you know when the when the time
came I just I couldn't make it happen so
you know sorry about that
let's see here Joe Johann
gamble putty thank you for the 199
what's with all the shots of phone power
lines
um I didn't I didn't pick up on that did
either one of you guys pick up on phones
or power lines
well we have uh that phone of course and
then uh he gives the burner phones to
Buddy and to Jeff
um I think he's asking about phone lines
though like shots of phone lines or
something that makes more sense
I don't know I didn't notice
me neither maybe it's you know
Frankenstein's electricity yeah with
your phone lines I mean the first scene
I thought of when uh I read this
question is the shot of the crossroads
I'm not sure if there were phone lines
in that shot uh awesome shot great shot
uh it showed up for a split second in a
VHS starting which I loved you see it
say record and then it pops up so it's
almost like now he's recording back over
the old Saul Goodman tapes which I just
I love that
um but that that was a great shot and it
echoed Kim at the crossroads when she I
guess that was in a little Crossroads
but when she was on the road and did the
U-turn uh after she found out about
casimiro's arm and uh similarly
self-destructive Choice yeah well she
does come to a Crossroads when she's um
on her way to Gus's house and she stops
at the light when the police text her
that's a Crossroads yeah for sure
that is true
um Paul Whelan thank you for the two
pound Kim is the only one who can save
Jimmy will she hey that's what we were
just talking about
um
you know as we didn't specifically say
will she or or would she want to I mean
the way that I I was you know Courtney
you and I were talking uh a little bit
after the episode
um and I was I was talking to Kiwi at
the same time we were all kind of
talking about different things from the
episode
and he you know I was I think it was him
that I was talking about like where
she's at and
until we know differently
my you know my thinking is that
we're still in
609 at the end you know she she still
cares for him deeply
doesn't believe that they should be
together or can be together
but you know I think that that she would
want him even if she's like completely
upset about the fact of what he did as
you know with Walter White and all that
if that's just coming out on the news
now you know obviously she reached out
to Francesca after that happened but I
mean I think even even then there's
nothing to tell us that that she would
somehow not want him to you know do
whatever he has to do in order to live a
better life rather than like you know
being like you know wanting to see him
go down or something like that so you
know well but does she have the
motivation to to try to fix this for him
you know what I mean I guess that's more
of what I think about because she's got
her own life she's got her own stuff
going on
and yeah you know I have a problem with
this question because it puts like it
puts all the responsibility kind of on
her like it's her job right and I
actually disagree Paul sorry to disagree
with you I think Jimmy is the only one
that can save himself yeah I talk reason
to him I think she might be able to
persuade him
um to to do the right thing but
ultimately he makes his own decisions
you know and that certainly at this
point it's been like what five years ish
since they broke up
yeah Courtney I was uh gonna say
something really similar where I was
trying to play that out in my head and
it just does not ring true to me at all
that if you have an addict for example
that there is this one person that if
they say the exact right thing it'll
turn them around and save them
um you have to want to be helped and I
just can't imagine what Kim could say to
him that would make him have this
Clarity that he hasn't had until now and
I think the thing he wants from her is
something that just doesn't exist
anymore that they can't be in a
relationship the way they used to be uh
it just yeah I think to your point he
has to save himself Kim I think could
play a role in that
um but I don't I can't see her being the
linchpin
um that that makes that happen yeah
maybe in some far-fetched scenario like
if she were to bargain with him like
turn yourself in I'll defend you or
something like that right that seems
really far-fetched but I couldn't
imagine three great spring sprinkler
system
yeah yeah I I think you know I think
those are those are great points and and
you know they they that definitely is is
the case like she can't she can't save
him and you know that it's possible that
he can't even save himself you know what
I mean but I think as far as his
destructive path you know that
if anybody would have the ability to
possibly get through to him you know
that he might actually listen to
then I think that that is the case like
what we were saying a few minutes ago
um the Judo Joker thank you five thank
you for the five dollars next week's
episode is titled Waterworks we learned
that Kim works or worked at a sprinkler
store
um could next week be post breakup Kim
episode yeah this is I think something
that we all probably thought of
um
I know Courtney and I were talking about
it yesterday
Water Works sprinkler store sound like
you go to get I mean obviously Water
Works is cue the Water Works like he you
know he said in earlier Seasons about
crying
that's another version but the the title
is usually you know apply to more than
one thing and I think
that was one of the things that I was
like yeah this this means we're going to
see her at work
in Florida knowing the way they've been
putting the synopsis together for the
last couple of episodes where they get
you to think one thing's gonna happen
you know a new player enters the game
I'm sure this is going to be like an old
love returns and it's like Jeff's
ex-girlfriend or something
Rex from Albuquerque
swimming finally
yeah that what did you guys think about
that send-off there's a lot of endings
and there was a lot of endings in this
but that one was kind of incomplete I
think you know just a little reference
to him but we never found out what
happened to him we're talking about the
Goldfish right yeah yeah I I'm hoping
that if we see Kim we'll see the we'll
see the goldfish with Kim that she took
him she got custody yeah exactly he
could be living a thriving down there in
Florida it might be the change of
scenery might have done done wonders for
him no more Lalo tapping on the glass
anymore down there
8hnic8 thank you for the 199 top tier
acting performances from Bob this second
half I agree uh I think that's
um objectively true
um but I I I I think that
in a way the the first part of the
Season you know it he was he was a
little bit in the background with
everything else that was going on and it
is nice to see as you know the the lead
the leading actor you know I mean to
actually see him get this much work you
know in these last few episodes uh I
actually just had a quick thought on
that which is
um we've seen so many times gene or
Jimmy turn on the Waterworks like with
Frank or at the insurance office uh when
he's trying to or at the adhering to get
his um uh license uh get reinstated yeah
yeah so now I'm wondering if next
episode we see the first legitimate like
true breakdown where Jimmy you know
confronts his emotions we see real Water
Works
I think we saw that in the the phone
booth I mean maybe not tears but that
was definitely an emotional breakdown
yeah that was for sure that was that was
real rage that wasn't uh that wasn't
performative at all yeah no I agree with
that I'm thinking more of the the
specific traumas that he's used like him
and his brother where he he uses it as a
tool but I definitely agree when he
kicks that phone booth apart that was
for sure legitimate you know that is go
ahead go ahead I was gonna say you do
raise a good point Gil about like
actually seeing the tears because
um there were a lot of like like fishing
and like water kind of references so
like when Francesca's taking the fishing
line to get it out of the old water pipe
it's all dried up and it's full of Sands
right so if we think of like water being
associated with this character maybe you
know it's he's in a bit of a drought and
um we might see the the dam break so to
speak next one maybe
sorry I mean
oh no it's cool
um
I I I lost my my thought but I don't
think it was it was too important it'll
come to me I'm sure
um spoon man thank you for whatever
ars-100 is because it's yellow I kind of
have an idea of what it what it means
why did Gene go immediately angry as
soon as we panned out when he was
calling Kim's work I don't think yelling
at Kim would be the first thing he does
after so many years
I and not my interpretation was that
what her that he had to be talking to
her in order to have that kind of
reaction
that was that was the way I thought of
it because like if he found out she died
it would go back to what we were saying
a second ago we might see that first
moment and that's what that was the
thought I lost also so it all comes full
circle here
thanks for this question that you asked
uh I don't know how long ago like an
hour ago or something
um it you know it it to see real not
it's not really about the emotion but
it's about him actually looking at that
stuff right it's it's like can he
actually
look at it for what it is not shove it
down not
keep you know going and doing scams and
hiring sex workers and everything else
to to try to
distract himself and actually look at it
and and hopefully move through it I mean
resolving that would be
the big picture stuff right
yeah and I just wanted to make the point
that um we've seen this character he
does not process his grief like a normal
person so after his brother's death he
you know does not process that normally
and then we never actually really get to
see the immediate aftermath of the
breakup right so we do this time Jump to
Saul so we see like the effect of it
like what the long-term effects was is
that he throws himself into this
character and it's all business from
like the moment his eyes open in the
morning he is doing everything he can to
not like deal with emotions not to feel
things so
um I think he's got obviously he's very
deeply repressed so whatever pain and
and frustration and anger that he felt
um following that breakup we didn't
really get to see it and he may have
never really processed it I mean if the
end result of that was turning into Saul
Goodman that's how profound it was
yeah I've been going through I've been
going back through a lot of their their
early scenes because I was I was doing a
video trying you know more been working
sort of slowly on a video about these
two and um it's funny because I know
they didn't plan it out you know
whenever
they didn't really know what was going
to happen as far as like what you know
what the future of the characters were
when they were writing a lot of these
scenes but it's really fun to see how
they went back on pulled on so many of
those those threads that they that they
sort of left there and um
it you know it's clear his pattern's
clear when you look at it backwards
knowing where you know knowing what you
know about 609 and and these last two
episodes
it's obvious like how how his mind
operates you know I mean like he is
early as whenever Marco died he he was
he was pushing stuff down you know what
I mean and he was throwing himself into
hanging out that at that uh hotel and
floating around and scamming people you
know for the you know whenever we first
see Giselle and everything so
it's it's pretty cool to look at it like
that to go back
can I just say one more thing about the
the phone call seeing
the way
to shot it shoot
it the way they chose to shoot it
reminded me of um the scene where Jimmy
has just um he's just been entered into
the New Mexico bar he's or just passed
right and like he goes and talks to
Chuck and he's like yo I can be you know
I can work here now and he's like I
gotta talk to the partners and then he's
in the mail room celebrating and they're
having a cake and I remember Howard
comes in and everyone leaves and then we
don't actually get to hear the
conversation we're on the outside of the
pane of glass and we just hear the fax
machine going that very much reminded me
of this scene and thinking of those two
different scenes and what they represent
to him it's like the two major hurts in
his life right so like the I know even
though it was how we're talking to him
it was ultimately the rejection of his
brother which he later learned is you
know it was all Chuck's doing
um that rejection and then also the
rejection from Kim so those are his two
great paints
yeah and that's one of the that's one of
the first um scenes that really stood
out to me when you know when I very you
know when this was when I was really
trying to decide do I like this show or
do I not like this show when it first
came out and all that
and um
I I really like that that choice there
because it doesn't matter we can see
what he we could see his reaction so it
doesn't really matter what what Howard's
saying there it's how it affects him you
know what I mean and um this had that
same this that had that same thing it's
like does it matter what Kim was saying
on the other line or or or you know does
it just serve the the the purpose of of
sending him on this path because is
there something that she could have said
that would have really made it different
you know what I mean like if he's if
he's if he was bound to spiral if it
wasn't this maybe it was something else
you know what I mean well that's a good
question right because we saw him get
some thrill out of the the thing the
heist them all heist in the previous
episode he puts together the shirt in
the tie and um puts it down but the way
and I I mentioned this in in one of my
videos that I saw that shirt and tie as
just another way of writing SG was here
on the wall right so like he's still
kind of flirting with it
um but like he decided to put the drink
down if we're going to think of it in
terms of addiction
um so it's not I don't know it's
impossible to say like what he had not
done this had that conversation not
happen but I think that definitely
pushed him over the edge but I think he
was already flirting with it he was
already kind of headed there he was at a
crossroads right he could have gone that
you know either way but I think um I I
definitely uh read it as I mean it's so
hard not to see the exact pattern
repeating itself where Kim rejected him
and that turned him into Saul Goodman
and now she's rejecting him again and
he's turning back into Saul Goodman down
to buying that foot machine
he gets the Bluetooth and all that but I
I do think that this episode really
reinforced the idea of he's stuck in
these patterns so I think it's fair to
say that even if this phone call hadn't
happened there's a very good chance he
would have relapsed in a similar way at
some point maybe not with so much
abandon and so much recklessness right
away it might have taken a little longer
but I definitely think he's reacting to
the trauma and the wound that's been
reopened by this call and he's trying
desperately to cover it up and that's
why he even though this guy has cancer
he's got to still go through it that he
can't stop for a second
gotta gotta feed the beast and numb the
pain that's right
big Ralph thank you for the five dollars
Pete slash Gill you're noticeably not
involved in this one Courtney the party
can officially begin when can we
speculate on the Kim call uh I I
you know with the the call we we've
talked we touched on it a lot since you
asked this uh
you know I I don't know if there's
anything else I'm looking at my notes
here to see if there's something else
you know the the other idea that that
that popped up to me was uh Ray C horns
um comment before about how there were
there were Fates worse than death
and I I don't think that I could pull
anything from this you know that says I
mean working at a Sprinkler Company
after being a a a partner track lawyer
at a big firm I mean it is a downgrade
um Florida so
I live in Florida so yeah so like
um you know what I mean like I don't
know if we can say anything else as far
as like is this a fate worse than death
you know until we actually see her and
see what what she's doing but definitely
a downgrade as far as uh you know the
job and future prospects you know when
you're working at you know retail or
whatever
foreign dead beef thank you for the five
why didn't Mike tell Saul that Walt's
brother-in-law is in the DEA
huge Miss from Saul maybe he needs a new
pi
yeah I mean
I guess if you know we were defending
Mike's choices here we would just say he
he probably didn't think he needed to
because he made a pretty solid case for
why Walt would would stay away from him
um
it is it is kind of important
information
I don't know you're trying to talk him
out of working with him yeah it might
help to say also big red flag
DEA he's his brother-in-law okay it's a
good I mean I know that they did the
comic the tying comic that um
you know showing how Mike did that
because that was sort of a question
because before Mike was a was a
established character you know he
it's sort of alluded to but we don't
really see how he ends up at the school
um I'm having a little bit of trouble
with the the timeline of of what
actually Mike knows whenever he comes in
on that that particular day you know it
might just be what you said where he
already saw enough to say this guy's not
worth your time so I'm not going to
bother to even continue looking into him
um so he just didn't get that fact yet
well he also researches them for Gus and
Gus is aware that he works if that he
has a brother-in-law in the DEA true
yeah yeah
Robert gay thank you for the 4.99 which
new Duo do you find more interesting
compelling useful to the story
Marion and Jeff or Walt and Jesse
I mean I think Marion and Jeff uh for
for Jimmy's story
um
just because I've already seen breaking
bad so I know what Walt and Jesse you
know what part they play in his future
um and and you know I think we touched
on this earlier I mean I don't think
that they they there were any real
shocking revelations in what we saw
there but it it as Gill pointed out you
know seeing it from his point of view
is really is is is really telling and
and it opens some doors that you know
add some some Dimensions that that they
can they can use again in the future
but Marion and Jeff I mean
Marion especially I just feel like
there's there's real potential in that
character and of course like Jeff is
like the only person that Gene knows in
Omaha as far as we can tell like so
he was pretty necessary for this whole
uh this whole
you know thing that's going on right now
because
you know he was he was done with him and
then he was like oh wait a minute you
know I needed to do this and he goes
right back to him because he's like
literally the only person he knows
I love the progression of Jeff's um rear
view mirror stairs because he it was
like iconic back in season four I think
the first time we saw it this just
what's in his eyes this weird kind of
menacing look fast forward to now where
it's just
so afraid of Gene he's like look I want
to do the deal but you know I'm just
thinking like maybe this is a little
crazy I enjoyed that
yeah there was a I pointed that on my
video too there was that there was a a
really great sort of call back to that
and you're just like man and you know
you you kind of feel for Jeff in that
spot because all of his points are
correct you know the the drugs might not
be working anymore the tape is gone
you're gonna have to break in like it's
not what he signed up for you know like
it it's definitely escalating fast and
he should be he should be scared yeah
and certainly since we know that Marion
um because she tells seen that her son
ran into some trouble he now lives at
home with her so she's going to I think
have a huge interest in what they were
doing out in the garage and and figuring
out what's going on there so I think
that yeah moment where I think it's
going to be important plot wise but even
just that that beat where she sees him
out there in the look of disappointment
and concern that really hit me because
when Gene when she says to Gene you know
you're a good influence on Jeff that
told me that he is still capable of
forming relationships in in a way where
people look at him as a good person and
for him to just soil that here yeah oh
yeah it's just I mean it's all part of
that downward spiral it's just hard to
watch yeah and yeah that's how like a
crossbow and she is when they take their
drinks outside you know yeah that's what
I was just gonna say too like I thought
that that was a really really it's small
it's not a huge thing but that
transition there it just it was showing
that one one like how how caught up he
is in this like how how much he needs to
like get out there and you know scam so
that he doesn't feel what he's feeling
but yeah you can't miss Carol Burnett's
reaction to that either like she's she's
absolutely almost heartbroken to see
them go like you know she's she's it's
hard to say like what her her
motivations are but it you know she she
definitely has a reaction there and you
know seeing her and Bob there I feel
like that was a really you know that was
a really loaded little scene in that
little transition from inside the
outside
yeah
oh Judy G thank you for the 49.99 that's
very generous I really appreciate it I
looked here to see if maybe there was
something to go along with it I don't
see it
um but thank you for that
David Earthling thank you for the 4.99
so it's Gene who's Breaking Bad
seems episodes 10 through 13 are jeans
El Camino
Sans a soft Landing in Alaska
yeah you know he is he's certainly the
one who was Breaking Bad
um
his his El Camino
I mean
it's an epilogue in a way I guess
it it feels like it's a more of a new
I feel like it's a it's more of a new
story than
than the way El Camino just really
exists to show us
what happened after you know from from
uh Jesse's point of view
yeah I don't know I don't know it
depends on how this ends but right now
it doesn't have that that same sense to
me either there weren't with Jesse there
weren't big open character threads like
there are with uh Jimmy right now like
his soul hangs in the balance and will
he redeem himself so plot wise there are
similarities and that it's after all the
crazy stuff went down what happens next
but I feel like thematically there's a
lot more here character-wise there's a
lot more here
yeah
says Shane says what we were all
thinking yeah I'm not going to read that
but I'll put that right there if you
guys want to read it
thank you for the 4.99 though Shane
Johann Gorder
SEK 50.
asked last episode
last EP F Sweden
about spoilers with actor's name and
intro pure new question a chance they
might kill Saul Now
he went too far in scams
hmm
what is I think for who is they do you
guys understand who they is in this
scenario I think maybe the the writers
ah okay
yeah I think we touched on this earlier
that it does feel like they want us to
believe that they might if not you know
it's definitely a possibility
um
do you guys have anything to add on that
no anything addition just the uh the
spoilers with the actor's names that was
something I was wondering about too
because in the opening credits you see
different actors names and uh especially
early on in the season when we kept
wondering when Lala was going to pop up
and you see Tony Dalton's name I'm like
oh they gave it away until you realize
that they still show like Michael
Mando's name in their episodes after he
his character died so
yeah I think uh I think they were saying
something about that in The Insider
podcast that they before they
um you know they had the the entire cast
regulars whether they appeared or they
didn't and I can't remember what the
point was that there was maybe something
that happened after
episode 10 as far as how that works but
um I can't remember sorry it's
contractual I thought that they had to
include their names yeah
yeah I think so
or some kind of Screen Actors Guild but
but since but it has changed to only
showing actors that are in the episodes
now
like if you watch if you watch the the
credits for uh 611 it doesn't have
Michael Mando or Patrick Fabian or any
of those names anymore
and they were all series regulars so I
don't know how the contracts work you
know like if it was only for the first
10 or something like that
ickley they brought something thank you
for the 4.99 what if Gene gets arrested
and they decide to parallel
chick
coming to save Jimmy in jail but instead
it's Kim
what is chick coming to save Jimmy's
team in jail come when Chuck bails them
out talk ah Chuck yeah okay okay
check yeah that was really throwing me
off I was like a chicken uh you know
like what is it but but instead it's Kim
and she refuses to save him I mean that
sounds dramatic you know that sounds
like wow wouldn't that be crazy but I
don't I don't I don't see a path to us
getting there um
for one she's not a lawyer last time we
saw her and for another it just doesn't
it doesn't seem to go along with the
character I think that she cares for him
foreign
I don't know it seems like a pretty
unsatisfying like her showing tough love
as he's in prison doesn't sound like a
cool ending to me
but we'll see I could be wrong I often
am
matu thank you for the 4.99 I thought it
was clever that Jesse sits facing the
back of the RV away from bad choice road
while Walt and Saul sit facing down said
road that is interesting I didn't think
about that neither of you guys pick up
on that
no I didn't think about it yeah I didn't
I was just like huh it's funny to see
Jesse uh forced to sit on the floor of
the RV while they get the seats
yeah I I like the um I I like the you
know the I didn't get to talk about it
too much in my video because it was just
like every everything that they said you
could just you could just break down
that scene and you know it would be a 10
or 15 minute video and it's on its own
because there are so many things you
know watching those two get back into
that role that were just super
satisfying you know you just sort of
forget how how great they are together
uh I'd also just we didn't talk about it
yet but the cold open where they
recreate the it wasn't me it was Ignacio
and actually you know film him replaying
those exact lines
um earlier today I kind of put them
right next to each other the breaking
bad version and then this version and it
feels like they cranked it up
um like he seems truly traumatized if
you watch this version of it it's like a
blood curdling scream when he sees that
grave in front of him and there's almost
tears in his eyes when he mentions Lalo
and uh I would just recommend
re-watching it and um it's it is really
intense especially if you compare it to
what it looked like in Breaking Bad and
then we come back to it later when
they're in the RV and Jimmy just does
not want to sit there in silence in the
dark after Jesse asked about Lalo and I
think that just showed how traumatized
he was like maybe for a second The Saul
Goodman veneer slipped when he said you
know it wasn't me it was Ignacio is he
just he can't just sit there with it he
needs to get back to work
yeah you know it's funny because I was I
was thinking I was trying to to figure
out a way to to get that Lalo that Lalo
mention into my video and I it it just
didn't feel essential for any of the
other stuff I was talking about and then
after the fact like you know how it
always goes when you finish something
and you're like all right this is done
and then you get the lightning bolt idea
that that you're waiting and I was
thinking about that like why did they
include that I mean obviously they
wanted to refer to when it was happening
but also because you know before that he
seems like you know he was pretty okay
with the whole getting uh kidnapped
thing you know like he doesn't really
seem that phased by it at all
so it just it's a great it's a great
little character moment whenever he just
hearing the name again
just to see how like continually like
he's haunted by that character you know
yeah it definitely seemed like some PTSD
and I'm thinking of
um the the Sal Goodman scene um at the
end of uh 609 when he's uh in his closet
and talking to Francesca and he says oh
that's my Xanax guy so he's
self-medicating I got the sense from
from that so and we certainly saw how he
reacted to the events in bag man after
seeing that
um so
or just because because of how it ended
with Kim we didn't really get to see
like the long-term effects of how Howard
maybe also affected him so I don't think
Saul is just the result of the breakup
with Kim I think it's a culmination of
of all of those events this is a deeply
traumatized person I'm not laughing
because it's funny I mean it's he is
deeply deeply traumatized yeah that's
something that I brought up a lot over
over you know the last couple Seasons
like you know the the whole the whole of
season four was about him not being able
to deal with what happened with Chuck
and he clearly never does that he he
jumps into changing his name and
throwing the the finger guns up at the
end after faking being like broken up
about it at the at the you know at the
reinstatement hearing
and then in season five he just gets
sucked into this friend of the cartel
business and then he goes through the
desert and he gets traumatized again
and then Howard does you know like it
it's not a really long span of time as
these things happen one right after the
other and and he's clearly never taken
any time to to deal with any of them so
you're absolutely correct you know it's
not just about Kim leaving Kim was sort
of like the thread of the person that
that still believed that he was
something other than like his base uh
you know
scammer
existence or whatever but um you know
it was just a it was just a one and a
sequence of a lot of different things
Amber t thank you for the 420 I don't
know if we have enough runway for a
whole Kim episode yeah I I don't think
so either but I do believe that it could
be possible that we just see what
happens inside that maybe we get a
little bit more Walton Jesse and it's
like heavily
a Kim episode you know like I I don't I
I feel like we we have to find out what
goes on
you know inside that I think it would be
a little bit too long to skip a whole
episode to leave that as a cliffhanger
but I don't know I mean they they've
they've done pretty good as far as as
structuring things so you know I'm not
too worried about it
what do you guys think does is are we
pressed for time here it doesn't really
feel like that to me
I don't think we're gonna get a full Kim
episode I expect some Kim scenes at
least but uh
who knows what they'll do
uh Cindy J thank you for the five
dollars any ideas what the individual
scenes with Walt and Jesse will be no
but I did see uh an interview with when
I was getting ready today when I was um
putting stuff together I did see an
interview with uh uh Bob Evan Kirk where
he alluded to it a little bit and uh I I
don't know he said that there was going
to be more I was a little surprised
um
but I think it'll be hmm do you guys
have any ideas like any any hints people
have been asking me this for weeks and I
and I I never really have anything that
feels like oh it's essential we we need
to see this thing you know
yeah I don't know for me uh I felt like
um come I was very curious coming into
this episode well I didn't know when it
was gonna happen I guess but I was very
curious what purpose they were going to
serve how it was going to feed into
Jimmy's story and I felt like in this
episode it was to help bring to the
Forefront of our minds the idea that
he's trapped in this repeating pattern I
feel like that Point's been made and of
course it will continue to be relevant
but I can't imagine we'll be flashing
back to Breaking Bad just so they can
once again say see he's still continuing
to repeat the pattern so it feels like
there'd be there need to be some other
reason you know whether it's thematic or
whether there is some logistical reason
we have to go back uh if there was some
interaction with Kim like we alluded to
as a possibility earlier uh so I guess
that's a long way of saying you know I
don't know
foreign
yeah I agree with all of what you're
saying there
um it's always been the thing is that
they show up it's got to be about
this story not not their story so much
and
you know they're gonna they'll just I
don't know what else they need to
explore in that timeline but if they're
gonna do it I have a feeling that it'll
make sense
Dylan kubit thank you for the 4.99 I
think Kim was turned away by Saul in the
Breaking Bad timeline which is why the
phone call with Gene had him so upset
turned away uh just doesn't seem likely
the only reason I could see him turn her
away
in the way you're describing it is that
he was he was thinking he was he's
thinking that he's protecting her for
some reason
um
and you know things don't get bad until
maybe like the last year that he's
involved with with Walt so I mean I
don't know maybe he could
I I don't it seems a little a little a
little far-fetched the one that she
would come back and and and want to get
back together with him based on how
things ended and then two that he would
be able to turn that down
Shane parole you got another one there
thank you for the five better spank Hank
data deficient thank you for the 4.99
the identity theft scheme is in line
with the Frankenstein Motif and seems
like a fitting downfall for Jimmy
the identity thing that's you wanna you
wanna you wanna reply to that Courtney
no since you're the since you're the
Frankenstein you brought Frankenstein
into the room
sure what you mean data deficient in
what way
yeah I was having a little bit of
trouble with that too yeah I'm not sure
I see the Frankenstein connection but it
is funny that at the end of two series
that are so focused on identity and
characters that are constantly shifting
constantly shifting into these discreet
identities that as viewers we can kind
of pull out at Walt Heisenberg Jimmy saw
Kim Giselle it is kind of funny and I
wonder if it's intentional that the
potentially final scam the big climax is
one that involves stealing people's
identities
yeah
I um I I was thinking about that it
I don't know what the implication is if
that's something
they really kind of don't explain how he
came up with that idea or or like how he
knows someone that they can go to to
sell this to
um I'm not sure if we really need to
know anything more about it but it is an
interesting choice that because I think
I think the point is sort of you know
that it's supposed to be kind of
um
you know it's an extra level of security
for them because you know they can do it
and they can plan it out in a way that
the person doesn't realize what's
happened until much later you know and
and it kind of makes it feel like Hey
we're not really hurting anyone here you
know we're just uh it's you know we're
just sort of tricking them and you know
whatever and um
it is a lot more malicious the way that
it plays out
Michael D thank you for the two dollars
what's your prediction for the BCS DVD
box set you know I'm not big on uh
not because I don't like it but just
because I I've been moving around you
know for for a lot of time or I I don't
I don't buy a lot of physical
media you know I haven't done that for I
don't know maybe 10 years
um
you guys buy box sets DVDs
stuff like that collectibles yeah I
probably will for this one
do you have any predictions for it like
I I've seen I've seen the um you know
like the deleted scenes and stuff like
that but
I don't I don't own any of the of the
actual DVD box sets maybe a briefcase
JMM
they got to do I feel like missed
opportunity if they don't make it look
like VHS tapes or at least like put an
episode on a VHS tape that I would buy
is a cool little collectible
yeah yeah I like both of those ideas
actually
um I can't think of anything else that
would that would be like a Cinnabon box
maybe but I guess that depends on on
what happens with Gene you know and
marketing too yeah maybe like an hhm
file box like they sent out those promos
uh yeah that's true uh I did see those
pictures of them anyways Sterling baytel
thank you for the five I hope the
writers are brave enough to give the
audience what they want that said Marion
kills Gene and she's Walter White's
mother
yeah I kind of went into why I don't
like any of the theories of Marion being
a secret identity
um it all stems from the idea that Jeff
met him randomly at the at the at the
hospital
so I don't think she's secretly someone
else but I think that this is kind
you're kind of joking around here a
little bit uh
am I reading that wrong
uh I don't think so I don't I don't
think this is a serious prediction yeah
so
um
I I think it would be funny if if Marion
killed Gene
um but it would just be a riot
but it it it might not make sense for
everything that that came before it
time will tell thank you for that for
five dollars though
um the haze records thank you for the
199 show ends with Kim taking a shower
with the salamancas
I've seen a lot of predictions and then
this is one I I just
definitely don't think is is what's
going to happen
I have a question in terms of
predictions do you think that
we will end the show in black and white
or in color
color
yeah I I always I always thought that
that there's just such a great that's
just such a great tool to have in the
box right whenever you're in black and
white to to switch back I mean The
Wizard of Oz you know what I mean like
that's one of the coolest things
like I remember from seeing it in
childhood you know it was like oh it was
black and white and now it's color you
know like that's just it's just such a
great effect that you don't really
always have that in your toolbox so you
have to use it right
yeah or I think uh going along with uh
the second to last question we got about
not giving the audience what they want
we all think they're going to go higher
Tech with color I say they go lower Tech
we're gonna get silent film with just
little title cards
that would be cool
all right thank you Michael D for the 10
Saul defends himself in in trial takes
the stand he's going to win Kim walks in
shades of Rebecca and Chuck he breaks
down it all spills out he finally
accepts responsibility for all he's done
yeah I've also kind of been sad I don't
really I don't really like the idea of
him
I don't really I don't really want it to
go to to a truck like switch back to
being a trial or a lawyer show
um I'm not saying they couldn't do it or
wouldn't pull it off it just doesn't it
just I I don't know I it doesn't seem
right for me at this point if he turns
himself in or if he gets caught or
whatever I don't I don't think we need
to to see
the specifics on how that plays out
afterwards you know I mean I think that
there were one another thing that came
up this week um
that I haven't mentioned in any videos
or had a chance to was that
the you know the writer director of this
episode Tom schnells he said that
um that whole thing with the flyer that
that there isn't a there isn't a reward
for for uh Jimmy out there for the five
million dollars there was that that
teaser and um
that was something that marketing made
up at least the flyer part of it
it's been a fun watching his Twitter the
last week or so just been going back and
forth with some unhappy fans
yeah he's he's pretty good at it yeah he
he doesn't he he answers more than a lot
of people would
um and you can tell he gets a little
provoked sometimes but I think he
handles himself pretty well I mean he I
don't he never like reaches like
meltdown or or just being like you know
um
needlessly kind of like uh you know
combative it's pretty I I I really do
enjoy his his Twitter
um watching his yeah and he answers a
lot of questions yeah he's great he's um
fantastic
yeah and uh I I've you know
mentioned I've praised him on here quite
a bit so I guess you know I don't really
need to do it every single time but it
is kind of sad it's his last episode
this time
um
I I think that I I think that out of the
two episodes he did this season I I
prefer
Planet execution but it's more of the
thing of like
where it fell in the story you know like
this is more this isn't this is there's
not there's no like this is a great
episode everything about it I mean
visually especially I think when you go
back and re-watch it there's some really
great shots in this
that um
you know that where they really use
black and white and the the switch of
going back and forth in the transitions
were all really great but I think
overall I think I I enjoyed uh 607 a bit
more
big Ralph thank you for the ten dollars
my theory of the day Kim told Jean she
was turning herself in for what they did
to Howard
it's eating her alive nothing to do with
the con Jean wants to get caught now
um
I don't know
um feels very coincidental that she's
thinking about turning herself in and
that happens to be when he calls I don't
know yeah five years later right is that
2010
this could be yeah actually this would
be like eight years later or and I'm
doing math totally wrongly six years
yeah
yeah so yeah that doesn't seem like it
that seemed like maybe like you said
pretty weird timing for her to just all
of a sudden be like okay I've been
living with this for six years
now I gotta turn myself in oh great
Jimmy called I can let him know what's
going on this this works out pretty good
I'm not I mean it's possible but
we have to find out more about what's
going on with her before we can really
even speculate is what what I would say
8-hnic8 thank you for the 4.99 at Gill
when you interviewed bitsui he showed
you a shirt from the job Kim has in
Florida I didn't get that reference when
I saw it was that a spoiler ghost
thoughts
yeah I'll admit that when he showed uh
so I don't know if you saw this Pete but
basically we interviewed Joe I listened
to it I didn't I didn't actually watch
it okay so like at the end of it he did
a little bit of a show and tell I think
probably fans of Better Call Saul have
heard the behind the scenes stories were
for important episodes they'll I don't
know if it actually might be every
episode I'm not sure um but they hand
out like swag t-shirts so for Nacho's
death episode 603 they gave out t-shirts
that showed like chips being dipped into
salsa and the sauce is kind of Dripping
like blood and he was showing us some
other shirts and one of them said Palm
Springs Sprinklers and at the time I
kind of smiled and nodded so I didn't
want to admit that there was a Breaking
Bad or Better Call Saul reference I
didn't get
um but now yeah I wonder maybe maybe we
weren't supposed to see that yet I'm not
sure but if it was a spoiler it was so
out of context nobody interpreted it
that way anyway so
yeah
there were some some filming photos that
that hinted that she was going to be in
um
in Florida that I saw a long time ago
like you know when they were filming and
uh
you know it's funny because there's a
couple things that that are out there
like that that keep getting recycled and
I keep seeing them but it's funny
because I find myself like so
like into what's happening in the
mechanics of each individual episode
that
I don't you know I mean like it it it
doesn't really fit like there's so much
to think about that those external
things don't even really seem like they
they influence like where I'm at you
know what I mean yeah no I had the same
kind of reaction when uh Courtney you
and I were talking about this right
before the stream but when I saw the
picture of Howard with the blood on his
hair you know you would think that by
the time Lalo walks into the room I
remember that picture and say oh I know
where this is going uh but somehow I get
so sucked into the story that usually
that stuff kind of Falls away
yeah it's not like the guiding you know
what I mean like it's not it's not
guiding my thoughts you know like it
like you said that
I I think I got in an argument with
somebody not like an actual argument but
like you know just a conversation
and you know they were like freaking out
like no way that that's that could
actually be blood I was like you know it
could be blood on Howard's head I mean
it's on its Temple you know like that
it's not nothing but you know I mean
like what can you say about that you
know like you know it could be anything
it's really we know so much about like
they do they build up the characters so
much and they have them
you know all this other stuff to think
about that you know that stuff is all
pretty far out of context when you see
it
Randy asuyamatsu thank you for the 199.
last scene last scene Kim taking the
oath for the Florida bar
um
yeah I mean
it does it doesn't seem climactic to me
at least for the other stories but there
is that teaser that's still out there of
her her reading the oath so we might see
something like that
almeida's Army thank you for the one
pound 79 it is the final scene the mer
the Moral Moral point of no return
yeah I think
I mean there's a couple things in this
that and and there is a progression to
it but I think I think that that's the
sense that you get there is that once he
breaks the window that is a point of no
return like that's the next
you know that's the next phase or I
don't know what the word would be but
you know like he he he take he's taking
things to a different place in that and
um
you can't forget that this is a guy who
is you know has got cancer and
um that adds a little bit to it as well
yeah the only thing I would add is uh
and not to like nitpick at the phrasing
of it I would just say I think it's a
point of no return for Jimmy but I
wouldn't necessarily say it's the moral
point of no return I feel like he's
crossed a lot of moral boundaries
already by the time he's gotten to this
point I think for me the the the point
of return was about the fact that he was
doing something so reckless that is so
likely to get him caught just because he
needs the thrill or he just can't
stomach the idea of of not winning
um when he's pulling off a scam
yeah and and it's sort of like I said
you know they there's levels to it
um when you think you've you've gone
down so far you can you can usually go a
bit farther given the given the
opportunity
thank you for the 4.99 again formula
four fours four eights what do you all
think happen at The Residence at the end
of the episode when the cops came
the cops showing up that was a teaser
that's sort of the mid credits teasers
they've been doing for the next episode
and um you know when I initially saw
that I said oh well they're here they're
they're at
this is going to be the next step in
what happens inside the cancer man's
house
um
and then when we were talking about it
Courtney you you brought the idea that
it could be
could be anywhere this could be a Gene's
place I don't think it is based on the
on the street there but Marion's place
is another one I think that you were
saying do you want to say anything about
that yeah sure so with these teasers if
you watch the teasers you'll I'm sure
have noticed the season in particular
they've been really really big on
misdirection and that they showed this
it's a just a couple seconds of some cop
cars right after the end of this episode
right where he's breaking into this
guy's house of course logically you're
gonna think oh the cops show up to this
house not necessarily right and maybe
something else entirely that happened so
one thing I just wanted to point out is
um that we see a Life Alert necklace
around Marion's neck and they very
prominently display it so I mean that
could just be like a choice in in
wardrobe right she's an older woman but
I think that it might come into play it
might be one of those Chekhov gun sort
of things where she might be in some
sort of situation where you know she
needs medical help
or maybe she hits it
um to surreptitiously call the
authorities or some you know there's a
lot of different possibilities so I
wouldn't I wouldn't put too much stock
into uh this this teaser really having
anything to do with the events at this
guy's house it could but it could just
as easily not
yeah someone on my timeline posted a
picture of the uh The Meta Medi alert
um necklace
and thought there might be something to
do that too because it is it is pretty
conspicuous you can't miss it
the other thing uh the the laptop that
seems like a really odd choice too I
mean there
of course you know when you have the
internet like Francesca brought up well
in the phone call you can look stuff up
so there's definitely a possibility that
she might learn about who Gene dakovic
really is now that she has the internet
um but uh we talked a little bit about
the teaser for the five million dollar
reward not being legit that's not real
however how do you guys feel about
American Greed since um they actually
did work on it right so the Better Call
Saul writers and team producers Etc did
work on on that production do you do you
consider that Canon
yeah I sort of do until
um told otherwise you know what I mean
like they promoted it it was on the AMC
Plus app you know I mean like where you
could watch it it wasn't you know like
they if they're not considering it Canon
then they should probably tell us that
you know
yeah I have to uh embarrassed to admit I
haven't watched it and partly because I
think in my head I've always categorized
it as all the extra stuff that they do
like slipping Jimmy the uh employee
train they just released a video of Bob
Odenkirk teaching you how to tie a tie I
think uh so I've watched some of that
stuff and now a lot of people have told
me American Greed is worth watching so
I've been meaning to
um but I I just haven't yet
but anyway I was thinking wouldn't it be
fun if like Marion sees it like she
watches it
finds like a YouTube clip of it or
something
yeah I I don't that's what I was trying
to just ascertain is when I think that
that happened though you know it's a
question
and they might not be able to tell us
whether it's Canon or not because you
know obviously he's not caught it
doesn't have an ending or anything as
far as we see you know it's really only
to the first commercial break of the
show
so we don't even know where it goes you
know yeah
but yeah I do think that's a good idea
of her you know seeing a clip of that on
her in between her hilarious and
enjoyable cat videos
that that Gene taught her how to find so
you know he would be he would be right
there in the pipeline of her her finding
out who he is
Christopher Dalton thank you for the two
convince and Peter not write one happy
ending
they think you have to readjust the
proper tone can they not write one happy
ending yeah you're right they even
capitalized the whole thing
is is Jesse's not somewhat happy
is El Camino and that that's not a happy
ending I mean I feel like given the
circumstances I can't imagine a happier
ending yeah
yeah it's sort of the best of the best
that he could hope for at that point I
mean he he went through the the ringer
to get there but yep
I feel the same way about Walt I feel
like he got a really good ending for him
considering everything possible he got
to accomplish what he wanted to
accomplish and he was going to die of
cancer anyway so he got to go out on his
own terms he got to avenge his
brother-in-law's death he got to take
out the
um Jack and his gang you know he got to
leave money for his family so
yeah I think that there's a there's a
pretty strong
uh you know for I mean I think that the
the finale uh Breaking Bad is is pretty
universally enjoyed but I mean there's a
pretty strong
criticism out there of the fact that he
did get that money to his family that I
that I kind of agree with like
um
you know they didn't want it and uh it's
kind of like for for the for the for the
character that he was
it's kind of like
undeserved you know what I mean like you
think about the idea of like what does
he deserve
um
he did like he said just sort of get
everything as good as he could in the
circumstances uh well speaking of
Endings by the way I think this is not
gonna have to bow out
um I do have one more thought on this
though which is that I I do really
appreciate the fact that I feel like
these writers will never just write an
ending to be miserable and sad for its
own sake I think they they kind of take
on the responsibility of of uh thinking
about the implications of the endings
they choose and I think they because the
show's Focus so much on it but I feel
like they think about morality and
almost not to sound cheesy but I think
they do consider what message are we
sending with what we show and how things
play out and even if I know there's
definitely disagreement over whether
Walt's got more than he deserved but I
think you can you can sense that they at
least thought about it
um and I do really appreciate that
yeah I mean I like I can see the
argument like and I kind of agree like
I'm even like in the initial watch I was
sort of like well that he he that I
don't know how I feel about that you
know I don't feel about him going to the
like almost just that part of him going
to Gretchen
and uh you know the gray matter people
and and doing that it just seemed like
that's odd did that really need to
happen but
um I I still think that it it that that
it's a great ending you know like it can
be it can be both of those things you
can have that issue for you know and and
still I mean watching it like I remember
watching the Breaking Bad finale the
first time and
man that was a ride you know what I mean
like that was
that was that was just like an
experience for sure quite a ride
yeah
all right thanks for having me on
thanks for coming out
um we'll see you again next week yeah
we'll see you next week Courtney was
great talking to you again and uh
everybody in the chat great talking to
all of you and I'll see you next week
all right and you know I I if you
haven't checked out his channel I do
have a link to that and his podcast in
the episode description so check that
out awesome thanks Pete take care all
right see you hi Gill
yeah so I'll hang around for a couple
more minutes
all right just let me know when you
gotta go and I'll be here until all the
questions are answered so you're welcome
to stay as long as you'd like
mod Mary thank you for the 4.99 maybe
Jeff wants out and called the police
from his cab to report a robbery
um I mean that seems a little
extreme for for the character as far as
you know he he was pretty into it he he
clearly is scared of what's Happening
do you think Courtney that he would be
so affected that he might back out and
they went out
no I mean but where they left it like he
was told to come back in 20 minutes so
maybe he does and maybe that's the drama
he doesn't come out or you know I I
don't imagine Jeff getting cold feet at
this moment I can see other things going
wrong though
yeah yeah that's I think I think Jeff is
I think he he looks up to to Gene
doesn't he he wants to show him that he
can exist in this world so
it would be it would seem a little
abrupt if he all of a sudden just sort
of
gave up that easily
Dana LS thank you for the five what do
you think about Gene just showing up
unexpectedly in Florida to see Kim
maybe like a Shawshank Redemption moment
far and free from it all
well there's nothing tying him to where
he's at I think that his his reaction to
What Francesca said indicates that he
does have plenty of money on top of
those diamonds or whatever like he's not
really hurting for cash so he could just
leave this this world that um had to
disappears set up for him
it all just really depends on that phone
call though it's sort of like this thing
you know like it's really hard to say
because
if he's just going to you know if if
it's just going to cause more problems
then I don't see him doing it you know
yeah I don't I don't see him going to
Florida to see her I can see them
reconnecting maybe in like Albuquerque
but I don't I mean he he knows where
she's at he could do it but the call is
is a pretty big indication that it would
be bad you know
he got he got some but until we know
what that is that they were talking
about then it's hard to say you know I I
don't know I made his army thank you
again for the one pound 79 Walton Jean
Breaking Bad on their 50th equals
perfection
yeah they're the the idea that this is
Saul's birthday whenever he gets that
call
is easy to overlook and with everything
else that's going on
um
it is his 50th is that is that true
I don't know but I I did notice that two
almeida's Army I think it's interesting
this sort of uh like ending on the
birthday being significant so
you know another year time to reflect on
maybe where you've come from or how how
you've grown or in this case maybe not
grown so
um you know it's sort of traditionally
taking stock of your life
or I guess some people do that but the
significance of the birthday does seem
seem important in this world
yeah the other thing and I I saw that
there was um
you know a lot of talk about the dates
and and somebody else said that the day
that
what was it I forget where I saw this
um
the day whenever
that he gets something happens on the
same day that he left uh New Hampshire
as well there's there's even another
um
parallel between Walton and Saul like
what they're doing but I can't it's it's
escaping me right now
like I whenever I was looking at the
dates last week it was you know it was
pretty clear that it was between when he
died and
um you know this call that was coming up
but then then I saw somebody else saying
that something happened before like you
know something that happened in the gene
timeline he made a decision or something
that that that corresponded with
uh Walt deciding to leave New Hampshire
before he went back and died
but I can't remember it's something
about the scam I guess but
um because you know some time passes
there so I don't know
fundamental Ivan s thank you for the
4.99 the end he will die of a heart
attack watching Kim with his daughter
and before
they saw Saul he fall and the camera
goes up like when Walter dies
do you think they that they have a
daughter
Courtney no and I think that comes from
they're on IMDb some time ago uh it had
been listed that there was this actress
playing daughter in episode 10 and of
course as we have found out IMDb is not
all that reliable and the actress I
think her name is Dominique pexa on
Instagram some time ago had posted her
character's name or something like that
that she was going to be on Better Call
Saul and it turns out I think she was in
the last episode I think she was one of
the Cinnabon customers at the end
um right before he uh goes on his lunch
break there's a woman and her daughter
and he's making a drink I think that's
the the daughter that was that people
have been talking about potentially
being sounds right yeah
I mean of course also the question that
was Kim pregnant when they broke up sure
it's possible I think it's a little soap
opera though I don't think they're gonna
go that way
um I I hope they um that way I hope that
they would treat Kim more as a
as a a fully developed character with
with agency Beyond
um and and story Beyond just like her
relationship to to the men in her life
or a child in her life right like I yeah
not that working at a sprinkler stores
is a great of a of a life but at least
it's it's a decision it's her choice
exactly
yeah that's what I always I always see
these people with um
theories that oh he's going to see her
and he's going to find out she moved on
and she's married and she has kids and
that seems just doesn't seem like the
character that we've we've known all
this time you know what I mean like oh
she just got away from Jimmy and she so
she could finally settle down you know
like it just it just doesn't seem like
her trajectory you know I'd like to see
something more more complicated and
interesting certainly could be but uh
you know if if that's what she wanted to
do that she wants to be happy but at
least the way the writers have have
talked about the character and the way
that racy horn has described her I don't
imagine that she's all that happy with
her life so
yeah this is something that we haven't
really we haven't really got to in uh
it's something I've been thinking about
I haven't really got to it in any of the
recent streams is like what do you think
is actually like what do you think the
prospects of how how she's doing is you
know because I thought that there was a
real
kind of hint that she was shifting blame
like she was taking on the blame for
herself in 609 and and and that led me
to believe that you know she would kind
of be
you know not in the greatest place when
she left there I mean a lot of time has
passed but you know there was that idea
of Fates that were worse than deaths and
and all this other stuff
um
I mean
what is what is your general feeling
like do you think that when she left
like that
she had the opposite reaction I mean
because when she left
Jimmy turned into Saul you know like
things got got got worse and and I kind
of feel like that there's a me there's a
chance that her her situation may be
similar
like not in that she's like just like
full-blown addiction but that maybe that
you know that
she can't compartmentalize the the the
the what happened in the same way that
he does or I don't know I mean I just
think that there's there's it's
definitely possible that that wherever
she's at it's a dark place
yeah and I really hope we do get more
Kim back story so I would I would really
appreciate that just not just because I
like the character but because she for
me has always been the biggest mystery
of the show how she's thinking and
feeling and so
um you know the what that she decided to
end the relationship
um showed that this is that she is able
to to make decisions where like other
characters can't right
um or they they choose something
different right where she was deciding
to step away so that was a very
conscious decision so I don't imagine
her being in a lot of trouble but I
don't imagine her being particularly
happy
um but uh all this to say I'm not really
sure I'm so curious to know what she's
been up to though and what her life has
been like after that because to your
point about how we see what happens to
Jimmy when they're breaking up she says
you know uh to get or a part we're okay
right and then but when we're together
we're poison and we see that he is I I
would say arguably worse off and um in
her absence right so and this isn't to
say that this was Kim's fault though
that that happened of course
um I'm curious to see also if if she to
to your your point has she been affected
in sort of the same way as she is she
coping or you know how she spiraled I
don't know
yeah that that would be even another
layer of the of a tragic kind of too
wouldn't if they if you say oh we have
to be apart from each other because
that's the only way that we're okay then
you both find out that you're not okay
and then the answer is still not like
well maybe we should get back together
then because that would
that's not going to fix it right yeah
I think Kim was um in many ways uh at
least in the beginning good for him
because uh I think people tend to forget
that he was kind of sleazy before he
started uh dating her like the way he
was in Cicero the sort of schemes and
cons he was playing with um with Marco
you know we see him sort of womanizing
and all that so I mean he still had a
conscience somewhat though and he wasn't
obviously to the extremes of Saul
Goodman but um it was I think really Kim
that that seeing what was possible with
her and uh that she was being uh
starting to become a lawyer that made
him want to Aspire to more so I think in
that regard she was a very positive
influence on him and then of course
things spiraled though as we know we saw
um that it you know they brought out the
worst in each other in some ways so I
don't know it's such a tragic love story
those two because the love is so sincere
and so genuine at least in my mind I
really see the the potential there for
for
um for goodness in both of them that it
just didn't go that way
yeah
I agree uh Kathy Bennett thank you for
the 9.99 the first get the first guy
Gene conned in this episode is Devin
retreat
buzz and home alone thank you for a
great Channel um I didn't recognize this
guy but I did he I did read something
about this he was uh
and and I couldn't remember home alone
all that well either to be honest but it
was his brother
um Macaulay Culkin's brother I think is
what does that sound right yeah I don't
I don't recognize the actor's name I
thought the guy kind of looked like um
or some wells
yeah I thought he was playing it like or
or someone's I I that's funny that you
say that because I was expecting when I
was reading about it like people would
point that out and you're the first
person that I heard say it but that was
100 on that too I was like is this guy
doing Orson Welles on purpose or is that
you know is there something more to this
kind of an obnoxious uh you know scammer
Orson Welles but but I thought like his
you know his delivery it seemed it
seemed like it really was a call to that
Matthew wait well that's way too many
unconnected letters in a row
Matthias
Matthias then there's a q
you see okay ql produces uh either way I
I know I butchered it but thank you for
the two r hi Pete any chance we see Ed's
book once again
I think it is implied in the
conversation with Mike that he has that
right
but we still haven't seen how he got it
um
I don't know because they mentioned
because it was implied in that
conversation I don't think that that
they Des they would necessarily go back
and do that
you know because we know that he said he
was going to sell it so we can just
assume that Saul bought it at some point
that's like one of those things that
would be fun if they answered it but I
wouldn't hold your breath
um so it's left
you see it would require another trip
back in time too to a different timeline
so that that makes it seem even less
likely you know as far as that goes
Fearless duck thank you for the 199.
favorite shot from the episode
um
I really liked the uh
uh the shot of him inside the phone
booth from above
that was really like kind of
claustrophobic and and you know sort of
that sense of the walls are closing in
on you as as this is going down
um I really like that one there was a
couple that were just uh uh you know
straight shots of the bars
um there was one where he was you know
sitting next to the guy with cancer and
they looked at each other and there was
really
really nice Symmetry and just the black
and white made that that looked so much
more Regal than it probably actually is
when you see it in color like it's
probably a pretty normal looking bar
um we kind of already mentioned the
overhead shot of the of the crosswords
that one was fantastic yeah the
crossroads certainly stands out I also
um I also really liked the phone booth
um scene uh I see a couple people have
mentioned it in the in the comments um
but yeah it also for me reminded me of
Goodfellas the scene where
Bob De Niro's character also Jimmy
um finds out that uh Joe Pesci's
character Tommy has been killed and
that's his reaction he you know bangs
the phone on the receiver and then he
kicks the glass so um I thought that was
a a fun little uh homage to uh Scorsese
whether that was intentional or not I
don't know
I think I think it was like you brought
this up yesterday and and so I didn't
mention it whenever I was was talking
about it because I didn't want to steal
your thunder but um the
I I did uh I I mean I did whenever he
was smashing that like I said when we
were talking that like I that seemed
really familiar but I thought maybe it
was a callback to something that
happened earlier in in Better Call Saul
or Breaking Bad and um you know I think
you're right on that it was it was a
good Fellas
um reference and that that I saw I
didn't read it but I saw there was a
post there they were they pointed out
some some other
um
other
comparisons to Goodfellas and and you
brought that up too about him saying oh
but the ca I didn't spend any money on
the computer it was no big deal it
wasn't a big you know there was there's
probably more of them in there if you
think about it yeah
Mike D thank you for the two dollars
Canadian the grave foreshadowing looks
Stark for Gene yeah and and we were the
last one was asking us about favorite
shots and then there was the transitions
because there were some some great
transitions in this one too and I think
the grave
um Gill brought this up earlier uh you
know what the way what I was thinking
about it was you know whenever you see
that
he you know is he he's it's the bed that
he made for himself in in Omaha you know
and and it kind of it it kind of comes
from that that first meeting in in some
ways and um
yeah I I thought that was you know like
I thought this was the uh camera flicker
or the candle flickering from 607 that
that was this episode's version of that
you know like that that visual thing
that you're just like wow that really
sticks with you yeah but certainly I
think a visual play on
um how did Gil say it I really like the
way he said it the um the grave that was
Doug first all becomes you know the the
bed that uh Gene has to lie in and
that's certainly how I read it too so he
made his bed sort of you know the
expression and now he's got a lie in it
and dug his own grave so to speak
um but also more symbolically right like
uh thinking in terms of like the the
death of the different iterations of
this character so like the end of Jimmy
the end of Saul the end of June so it
may have you know something some some
play there
yeah and they said in The Insider
podcast that they had they had to that
that place where they went originally no
longer existed so they had to completely
recreate this this grave site you know
the whole going out to the desert thing
in a different place than what they did
and uh
better uh Breaking Bad season two
episode eight
Rohan Pandy thank you for 100 of those
things uh was there a hint of sympathy
for Walt
from Saul before he decides to visit the
school or just money also does Gene
repent his Destiny or his choices
was there a hint of sympathy for Walt
from Saul before he decides to visit the
school or just money
I mean I think he I think he I don't I
don't know exactly what you're going for
with sympathy but I think that he saw
this as an opportunity
I think that you know he he thought he
saw this as a way to
keep the high going you know like he
he's he's been away from he's been away
from uh his life with Kim for for four
years at this point whenever this
happens but
part of what his coping mechanism is is
that he has to keep doing it you know he
has to he has to keep going he can't he
can't sit still he can't sit with his
thoughts he has to continue to numb
things so
I I read it as you know he looks at Walt
as a way to to keep that going I mean
the money is kind of secondary to the
the effect of
you know being able to manipulate this
situation and to get away with you know
what what they what they're doing
there is also a scene in Breaking Bad
it's it's um been a while I don't
remember exactly what
season or even what episode but um Saul
and Walter talking and uh his cancer
comes up and it's something along the
lines of of Saul asking him like how
serious it was or is and he says um you
know that's a shame we could have made
some some real money together right so
uh when I don't know if it's like after
a scan or or something like that I
thought there might have been a little
continuity here issue here because we
like tell
um but I didn't go back to double check
I don't know if anybody out there knows
what I'm talking about but um I I
clearly remember there being a
conversation between Walt and Saul in
Breaking Bad about his cancer diagnosis
does that sound familiar
yeah but like you said I can't I can't
give you I didn't it's not something I
went back and looked at yesterday so I I
can't say other than generally I think
there is but I I don't have a specific
and he does say that to this cancer guy
uh you know he's like he he does you
know briefly seem like he's sympathetic
like you know should you be should you
be mixing that you know alcohol with
your your pills or whatever and is it is
it bad
um you know the guy says it's not the
good kind and like there is a good kind
so yeah I I don't I mean there is some
there is some Humanity inside him but
um whenever he's focused on on this you
know like it I think that really kind of
shows that once once he has it in his
head that this is what he needs to do
there's really no stopping it you know
yeah and that's such a a great Point
thinking of that scene though when he's
talking to the the cancer patient and he
says you know should you be drinking and
then the guy says something of like
whatever the 2010 version of YOLO is
like I think he says you only go around
once and I wonder if that was like the
the moment for for Gene where he was
like I'm going to go ahead with the con
I wonder if like he was debating about
whether or not he actually wanted to go
through with it or if that was all just
an Act was he just like feigning you
know
um sympathy such as part of the the act
because for seconds when they walked
outside and the cab came up and the guy
was like do you want to take it Vic like
the guy was was different from some of
the other marks right like he seemed
more more human in a lot of ways I think
they were trying to you know um Garner
our sympathy for this guy but for a
split second I thought he might actually
get in the cab with Jeff himself just so
that they wouldn't pull the con I don't
know if anyone else felt that way
watching that scene I thought for a
second he might call that off
yeah they played they played with the
idea that he could and and I had to go
back and watch it to see because I I
think it's interesting what you're
saying there that maybe he was just
pretending the whole time I mean we saw
him we've definitely seen him do that
and do it um believably and and in
serious situations you know
um
just thinking again back to like 410 uh
you know crying at the thing like he he
even had Kim believed that it was real
and
uh yeah I'm gonna I'm definitely gonna
look at that again I I just I didn't
pick up on it the first time I thought
that we were just sort of like supposed
to say like will he or want he you know
because we know
it's an opportunity for him to slow down
give me a little bit of the moment
between Waltz and
was his name Mark Margolis James
Jane Doctor that plays uh Hector yeah
your goal is Jane's dad
um
and it was something that
um that uh he said to uh to uh Walt that
made him actually go back to to Jesse's
apartment he was like it's family you
can't give up on them and the sort of
YOLO or you only go around once comment
I think is maybe something a similar
moment for for Gene where he's like I'm
going to push forward with this yeah
because that is sort of what he tells
buddy later you know the guy's gonna die
anyways
um
it doesn't matter
yeah
Don Margolis
uh and uh the last part here says does
Gene repent his Destiny or his choices
and I think that's the big question that
we don't know that's what's keeping us
on the edge of our seats going into the
finale
Randy soyamatsu thank you for the 199 on
the phone Kim says never call
comma Saul exclamation point very nice
Oscar Alvarez thank you for the five
euro I believe they will show us how
Saul Goodman is response responsible of
triggering Walter White to be Heisenberg
what do you think
um
yeah I don't I don't agree with this uh
I think
I don't think that they made this show
to change the understandings you know
the understanding of that character I
think that
there's a lot more to Walter White and
and how has cancer diagnosis and the
choices he made revealed who he was
you know how that gave him the chance to
kind of embrace this side of himself
um you know Saul is he obviously is
playing a role in setting things up but
I don't think he has any real influence
on who Walter White is at his core and
that's the story that they told so I
don't think they're trying to rewrite
that do you agree or disagree coordinate
I don't think he's responsible for
triggering Walter White to be Heisenberg
I think he was already on that
trajectory but he certainly wants these
characters get in Orbit of each other
they certainly uh
I they they do influence each other and
I think that's a point that that both
shows have tried to make the way that
like how like when they come into
contact with each other they are
responsible in some ways for for
influencing them but ultimately it's up
to the individual characters right
yeah and that's sort of what I was
saying in my video was that you know
that it's the story of these two people
coming together and that and that
happening
and then you know if you if you if you
think that through if if they hadn't
come together well maybe there would
have been another event that would have
got them to the same place if if that's
the way it was going to play out you
know what I mean but obviously when you
have two people that are as uh you know
they're they're they're substantial
these characters you know and and
they're the strange ways that they they
operate you know there's a lot of
potential for
uh things to ramp up whenever they they
come in contact with each other
Andrew Boone thank you for the 10 is it
just me or is anyone else at the point
where you just stop speculating
whatever I predict it's never as good as
what happens great place to be as a fan
just sit back and Trust show or honestly
yeah I mean I think
uh you know uh intellectually sometimes
I get to that place but
it's also really hard not to
um
kind of run scenarios in my head you
know like I could say that like yeah you
know I realize that
um it's better to just enjoy the ride
and agree with what you're saying there
that
you know probably the best uh thing
that's going to happen is is what they
that they figured out and you know part
of that is going to be the surprise of
it but I you know I can't really help
myself I still will speculate either way
well I think that the show kind of
encourages it right so Andrew I do agree
with you though I'm kind of at the point
right now where I'm like I really don't
know how they're gonna end this and I
love that it is a great place to be as a
fan because it's enjoyable right like if
it was completely predictable it would
be boring why would we watch it but I
find that this is a show that really
rewards us for paying attention to the
details right so like they'll show us
something like three years ago and it
will come into play now so like the
conversation about um between Saul and
Francesca about the phone call at 3 pm
as soon as I saw the 205 on that clock
in the the kids apartment I was like
this is phone call day you know so
um and being able to recall those
details takes studying it right and of
course I think we study it everyone here
where we're super fans right
um more so than like the Casual viewer
but when you're studying it and you're
thinking about it and you're trying to
imagine like what could that phone call
mean it's really hard not to to go there
and to speculate what's going to happen
absolutely Dapper Dave 2021 thank you
for the ten dollars kind of like the
theory that Carol Burnett character sees
the American Greed episode of Jimmy
Mcgill and reports him also kind of sad
such a great character like Kim working
in a sprinkler store
I the reporting part of that I mean I I
agree and we and we touched on this
before the reporting part on that though
that seems like a wasted opportunity of
where you could have her use it against
him especially now that we know that
there's not a five million dollar reward
out there
I kind of really like the idea of Carol
Burnett getting some some information on
Gene and then you know trying to exert
that over him you know what I mean like
trying to get him to do something that
she wants him to do rather than just
calling the the authorities but
either way I I think we can all agree
that that you know we think that she'll
play a bigger role cut you off it would
be very poetic too when you consider how
he got into elder law and how he took
advantage of like poor Irene Landry but
he did something Justice for Irene yes
foreign
even if it's all these years later uh
you know I think we all still have a
it's a sore spot for everyone let's
watch this show
absolutely
Steve throw threw up
five thank you for the five a nice E.T
um
icon there is there still a chance that
Gene or Kim will somehow tell Cheryl
what really happened to Howard
can't picture any other way of
redemption
[Music]
um
I don't know uh
I mean my initial reaction is is that
we've moved past that
um obviously Cheryl probably hasn't so
that I'm not saying it in that way but
she Howard was you know
it feels like that chapter is closed I
don't know what do you think Courtney I
didn't see it Steve threw up
um I can definitely see that and uh I
think it would be a sort of nice
Redemptive uh end for for uh maybe uh
Jimmy or Kim to come forward and
actually say that but I think like that
would be like it would mean that he had
to come forward and turn himself in
entirely and then that way he could like
share all those other details I can't
imagine them doing it any other way
unless like it sort of ends with him
coming to terms and and uh owning up to
what he did entirely and giving that
sense of closure again I I it's hard not
to draw the parallels to Breaking Bad
and of course this is a separate show
and we shouldn't look to see like the
blueprint of Breaking Bad for what they
will do in Better Call Saul but I think
of like the lottery ticket with the
coordinates for Hank and um and
that closure being given to Marie and to
um Steve Gomez's family even though they
knew that they were dead right like
Waltz confirmed that on the phone so it
was you know
I was still I think a moment so I can
see it happening yeah I I like what the
the way that you're spinning that there
because yeah as an individual act it
does it seems not that likely but as
part of
everything coming out and then and then
taking
that part of it you know or or
addressing that part of what's happened
then yeah that makes a lot of sense but
you know just to just to like seek out
Cheryl independently and and none of the
rest of it happening that that's the
part where I I feel like it's it's a
little bit of a stretch
Dan drazeki no I said it wrong but Dan D
uh thank you for the five Waterworks is
two spaces behind the go to jail space
in Monopoly
this is true
spots before it though so it's like uh
go to jail is in the corner and then
it's two spots before it
so it doesn't exactly line up with the
number of episodes that are remaining oh
it's too away from the go to jail so
there's like one other
um utility between Water Works and the
go to jail so I mean it would be a fun
little little uh clue that they left for
us if that is the end result but it
could just simply not mean anything
these writers are they always crack me
up whenever they're talking about and
they're like did you mean to do that
like when they were asking um Tom
schnells about Lalo spinning on the the
silencer or the suppressor whatever you
call it and if like he meant that to
mirror the um the spinning of the soda
can he's like no I didn't mean that yeah
yeah things are just happy accidents
yeah
yeah and that's what I was thinking when
I was looking back at their story too
because like I said you know when you're
watching those scenes that that that
they didn't have a plan but they wrote
it in a way that there was a lot of
stuff that they could use if they wanted
to you know what I mean and I think that
that is something that they can do in a
prequel series of a really famous
you know coming off a really famous show
that was super popular and like you said
that we know we're trained to look at
all the details you know there's there's
so many options they have in that of
just throwing details in there and um
and just sort of having a visual
language that
they can go back and say oh yeah well we
had this so we can make that
turn out to be something else down the
road you know
if I if I would if I could interview
Peter Gould or one of those guys that
would be one of the questions I would
ask them is how how they did they really
think about that stuff or is it just
actually just look that way to us
because we spend so much time pouring
over the details because I thought you
know one of the things about the opening
teaser in this season and hearing them
talk about that
and how they kind of front loaded uh
pre-easter eggs in that in there you
know what I mean I I it's just it's such
a rich uh the universe is such a rich
place with so many different things that
you know you don't always have with the
TV show you know we got six seasons of
this five seasons of Breaking Bad
tons of different stuff and and it makes
it you know something I'm gonna
definitely miss when it's when it's gone
oh definitely
Harley O'Keefe thank you for the four
pound 49 what do you guys think he went
for a more malicious scam than before
in season one and two it was some rich
guy for a couple Grand now it's identity
theft
yeah I I I mean
I think it's supposed to like I said
earlier I think it's supposed to show a
natural progression of like you know
what with with addiction if we're
talking about addiction and
uh you know substance abuse
there's you have to keep you know I
guess you have to after a while you get
a tolerance or something right you know
the effect wears off you need to you
need to take more
to get the same effect and I think that
we see that happening in the progression
of his uh his scams
I think we see a very man right this
he's I don't think he's doing this for
fun this is not getting the same thrill
out of it as he was just even
an episode ago right it's a compulsive
like a the I know you've been saying
this a lot Pete um likening it to an
addiction but this is like a
um like an addict going on a bender you
know after being sober for a short
period of time
hmm
Robert gay thank you for the 199.
compare the lyrics of Brandy
to Kim's present uh I don't think I know
the lyrics
uh that well
it's the the thing is
she's married to the Sea right isn't
that the the little refrain in there
I'm not as familiar with the song but
yeah that sounds right I haven't studied
it
that's one of those songs that I I can
hear it and I might even be able to sing
along with it because it's just sort of
like a like a soft rock you know what I
mean like it fits into so many
background music situations but um I I
don't know what that the lyrics are
actually about
Florida now so you know
yeah that's what I was thinking like
that that's what I that's what jumped
out at me from whenever he was doing the
karaoke was that there's a thing like
but she's married to the sea or
something
and she's in Florida near the ocean
David Seitz Jr thank you for the ten
dollars I can't stop thinking about how
large that RV interior looks anyone else
notice that
um no I mean I thought it looked uh
realistic
was it always a set I mean they have a
real RV that they drive around
are there do you think there's some
shots that are that are in an actual
interior or is it always a sound stage
for Breaking Bad I think they did both
right yeah that's what I would think too
that they used
so for this one um I believe that they
had to build something new because they
didn't have the original I don't know I
could be wrong about that
Insider
didn't really think too much about it
looking different I know a couple people
have noted noted that that um it didn't
look the same as looked and Breaking Bad
and a lot of people have also talked
about how different Jesse looks you know
but that's you know it's 15 years so
you know it's I I think they they did a
a as good of a job as they could with um
with that
yeah it didn't jump out to me David but
apparently that there is some chatter
about it Skyler Myers thank you for the
five dollars I wonder if Waterworks
could refer to the bottles of water in
the car with barbiturates Ah that's an
interesting take I mean we like I said I
think it it will have something to do
with Kim but there's going to be
multiple meetings
um
yeah barbiturates those Knock You Out
um
and water is a good delivery system
um one thing that stood out to me is uh
in the previous
um episode when they were doing the
Montage and uh every night that Gene
would lock up Cinnabon he would like you
know the little cage that he would lock
up the last thing he would do before
moving on it was the cage over water
bottle so
um for the water bottles or what you
know will end up leading him to be
trapped in some capacity whether that
means literal jail or
trapped in some other way so that could
be another carryover that's a nice catch
I like that Skyler
yeah
agreed Carl Borchers thank you for the
999. maybe when Saul heard Skyler got
off the hook he decided to make a call
like Walt did to protect her
fake outrage and blame to make it appear
that she was against everything he did I
think it was genuine I mean we we've
we've kind of mentioned it a couple
times here I I think that
for me and and you know that obviously I
could just be wrong and and that could
be uh influencing
the way that I experienced it but I just
thought that you know his his his real
rage you know that was the indication
that he he actually talked to her
because
you know that's where that could come
from you know what I mean
um
to protect her from so unless she was
that she was involved in some capacity
during the Breaking Bad timeline
although I would be surprised I didn't
get that impression I think like once
she walked out she was she was done but
we'll see I mean there's still there's
still some story left to tell so you
could be onto something Carl but as of
right now with the information that we
have I I agree with you Pete I don't I I
felt that was that was real emotion
coming through there
thanks Carl again store sir
torchington199 thank you Waterworks will
be a life and death game of Monopoly
uh
life inductive Monopoly is about
being a landlord isn't it
what's the purpose of the game Monopoly
yeah Francesca's a landlord maybe it's
her life and death game
hmm
yeah
what I remember about I haven't played
Monopoly in a long time but what I
remember about Monopoly is that it
always looked so cool you know because
you had the bank and you had the money
and you had all the little pieces and
stuff
but I never remember finishing a game
because it just seemed like it it uh you
know you start playing it and then
somebody gets
the lucky roles and has all the control
stuff and they just beat everybody over
the head for rent for the rest of the
game
I remember trying to always get
Boardwalk first I was like when I was a
kid
yeah because if you had it then you
could just you could always you always
had a source of income that that meant
that the game just went on forever
Marshall Higgins thank you for the five
did Kim use Jimmy to destroy hhm she won
a revenge on the good side of the law
while Gus used Heisenberg to destroy the
cartel
I think this premise is assuming that
like she that that was always her plan
was to destroy hhm I don't think that
was like an actual agenda that Kim had
um no I think she
go ahead I'm gonna say I think she had
sort of a you know a grudge against
Howard but I don't think that's what
motivated her I think she just enjoyed
you know doing the little schemes with
Jimmy and it really spiraled out of
control
yeah and the way she was introduced was
that she she was actually you know uh
she was uh grateful for for what for the
opportunity that she had at hhm it was
definitely a a path you know to to a
better
um situation so
I I don't think that would really track
if it was always her plan
472 thank you for the five maybe we'll
see a Jane type scene with Marion
maybe she confronts Gene but slips on
ice
Water Works question mark and he has a
choice to save her or not Life Alert
man that would be brutal
yeah that was actually uh this was a
point that I made in my breakdown of the
last episode but that was when I was
thinking that um perhaps
um Marion was on to him and I still
think she might be part of the story
that brings him down I still think she's
uh she's there but
um I I really saw her as a much more I
didn't see her as as not that she's not
cunning but I didn't get the sense that
she was aware of of who he was at this
point I think she's slowly starting to
piece things together a little bit but
that was a point that I made that she
could be the Jane that is like the
obstacle but I I have revised that
opinion since now that we saw that he
act and he decided to um engage with uh
Jeff and and this uh this Con that he's
doing now because before when they left
last episode I thought okay well the it
seems like everything's been all like
neatly wrapped up so maybe she's gonna
be the the um obstacle that pops up but
no it's Gene himself is the obstacle
that's popping up right like in terms of
um
risk he's putting himself at risk
yeah
yeah
that
um
I'm not sure like I said I hadn't really
I hadn't really considered that in um
man if you really wanted to make us not
like
the Jimmy McGill character you know like
they're really to abandon him once and
for all let him let Carol Burnett's
character die on screen that would
definitely work right
Cal thank you for the 179 pound possible
reaction with barbiturates in cancer
meds
um
it's outside of my my uh knowledge I
don't I really don't know
I think it's possible sure
yeah I guess the question is to what end
I mean would he then save the guy
because he's there to break into his
house
or is this another Jane let let the guy
die and that would be bad I mean
it would depend I guess but
there's any time you're talking about
medication there could be
uh you know interactions barbiturates
they don't really give to people anymore
because they're they're kind of
they've kind of been replaced by
um
what's the other one uh you mentioned
Xanax earlier whether it's called
benzodiazepines or something
I thought yeah
I think because I don't know I thought I
think barbiturates that's like Quaaludes
or something isn't it yeah it's it's um
that's my understanding of it too like
they really knock you out like I think
um
they've also been used and I don't want
to say the word but date
blank for another word
yeah okay
yeah I I think those I mean
I'm I'm not young and and those weren't
something that people talked about even
in my uh you know my youth of like
things that you did for fun or whatever
you know lunar orbit thank you for the
five dollars Canadian I'm thinking
Marion is suspicious of what Gene and
Jeff are up to and she's going to use
that new laptop to do some digging in
the jeans past
foreign
there's a real possibility we brought
that up earlier and I would have to
agree with you Luna orbit I think
there's a real chance that might happen
Danny O'Brien thank you for the 199
Menace versus apprehensive jeff which
actor did better
um
I think they're both pretty solid I know
people felt there was and I and I do
think that that they do the character is
different you know they're the
I I read that they said that they wrote
it for Don Harvey they didn't write it
differently you know it's just two
people interpreting something their own
way and at this point you know it's just
it it's kind of like something I didn't
really even think about in this episode
but I wouldn't say that that makes
him better than Don Harvey I just think
that you know it worked out that they
had two pretty good actors for the role
agreed all right Dylan kubit thank you
for the 4.99 I think that Kim tried to
reach out to Saul in the Breaking Bad
timeline and he rejected her
and now that he reached backed out she
rejected him making him mad
yeah we some another uh
this question came up once before we've
already we've already addressed it but I
just don't think it makes sense for me
but
I don't know you're you're has your
opinion changed since the last time we
looked at it Courtney no
okay
it's your Karis [ __ ] thank you for the
4.99 I think Kim told him
to turn himself in it ends with Jimmy in
prison
Kim comes to visit through the glass
using the phones bittersweet ending
yeah I think we touched on it you know
she could be telling him that because
that would be uh
if she understands that the way that he
deals with
what's happening is by being Saul
then you know that's a that's a that's
perfectly sensible for her to say look
you can't keep doing this you know it's
never going to end you know the kind of
a call back to what uh
Papa Varga said to Mike you know it
never ends
the only way you can break the only way
you can break this cycle is if you turn
yourself in if you take responsibility
yeah it would be a bittersweet ending I
would be okay with that
yeah
it just I would just I would just add
though
um that I hope that we would find out
more about what's going on with her
not this that she comes to
talk to him in the jail and we're just
there's still tons of mystery around
what what she's been up to for the last
six years I would find that a little
unsatisfying yeah
agreed yeah Devin Denman thank you for
the seven dollars Walt Jesse are said to
have one scene left each what are
thoughts on Jessie's being with Mike and
Waltz being with Gus
to close out those BCS arcs
I'm really up for anything
um that sounds cool
uh but you know I I don't have strong I
don't have
I don't have strong feelings about how
exactly I'd like to see that happen I
mean I did like the dynamic that Mike
has with Jesse
I just have a hard time seeing how that
influences or reflects the story of of
Saul Jimmy Gene
but I do like it so if they can make it
work I would watch it and um
again with Gus I don't really need to
see him he had a great ending in in 609
um a surprisingly good ending when you
thought that that story was already kind
of over and so
um again if he if they have a they can
concoct the way that him meeting with
Gus would would be relevant to what's
happening with Jimmy and what's leading
up to the finale of this this series
then I'd watch it
all right yeah I don't I don't have any
real ideas either I I Echo you Pete I
think whatever they show it's going to
have to further the storyline somehow
and I agree I think that Mike and Gus's
uh storylines were wrapped up really
nicely it was a nice surprise to see
Mike in this one I thought yeah so we'll
see
yeah you know I mean it's like he can
you can totally bring those characters
back but it it's not that there's
nothing really else to tell about them
you know like we know the story of of
Gus and uh Walter White
Luke Duke thank you for the five dollars
Canadian did Kim tell Saul that she
wants to confess to Howard death and
cover-up
conscience is expensive well we we
touched on this stuff just a little
while ago
and our consensus was that it would be
very
suspicious the timing of it all so much
later for that to come up right when he
called
Henry Lemoine thank you for the 4.99 do
you think Jeff will die
also do you think if Gene gets caught
and Spills everything he will tell the
truth about Howard and say he was
murdered
Jeff I I hadn't thought about Jeff dying
he doesn't seem to be in
you know I think about him getting
caught or getting in trouble or playing
a role in getting them brought down but
dying seems like there's there'll be
some other steps between point a and
point B that we have to get to in order
for him to be
you know in danger that way
I thought he might have killed himself
when he knocked his head maybe like you
know uh
practice skull but in the last episode
when he fell yeah but I don't see him
dying
um but I as to the second part we did
talk about this a little bit earlier uh
I think if he does get caught or he
turns himself in I think there is a
chance that he will talk about what
happened to Howard because someone else
had asked if like he would reach out to
um to Cheryl and we were kind of of the
consensus that no we don't see that
happening directly but could see him
telling you know confessing to to
everything that happened at some point
maybe I think that would be a great
ending
yeah absolutely
Jay thank you for the five thoughts on
or how BCS relates to the biblical Paul
Saul
it relates to how often Jimmy quotes the
Bible in season 0102 but not after
it's not really my area of expertise
what do you know about
Paul slash Saul
that's just a whole long other
discussion to have
um but I think it raises an interesting
question I think there are a lot of
biblical references throughout
um throughout the story
so but it's it's a little late and I was
actually uh that's a good question Jay
it's a good question and maybe I'll
we'll be able to talk about it more some
other time but
I think I'm gonna
to uh sign out tonight
all right
well thanks for coming out
um
I'm not sure I I do think I'm gonna be
doing Saturday so you're welcome to come
back or or next Tuesday
we can talk about that yeah I'll be in
touch yeah
um you can go ahead and like I said
about Gil if you guys haven't checked
out her Channel you should definitely do
that I put a link to it in my
description what do you want to tell
them about that or plug before you go
uh Courtney's reviews uh if you haven't
checked it out it's better call us all
stuff um so
kind of you know what we all do talk
about the episodes
thank you uh for having me again Pete uh
always fun thank you all for your
questions
yeah thanks for coming out and don't
worry guys I see that there's still a
lot of questions here I'm going to
answer them all and uh just I'll um
yeah just uh that's about it I guess uh
thanks for coming thanks uh we'll
hopefully see you again
have a good one yeah take care good
night
all right let's see
Jonathan Goldstein thank you for the 199
it's an identity purchaser supposed to
be vacuum guy
no I don't think so uh he's in
Albuquerque
the identity purchaser is in Omaha
Richie MC thank you for the two dollars
if no Lyle we riot in agreement
that's going to have to be on chat
um
I personally I like Lyle he's a fun
character but I would be totally fine
with not ever seeing
without ever seeing him again
now that we've moved into
Breaking Bad and Gene timelines
Matt polikin thank you for the 4.99
perfect sing to bring the perfect scene
to bring back Walton Jesse I know you
all don't care about the Aging of the
characters but they did a good job of
hiding their ages
yeah it's funny because
there was such a stirrer over the bald
cap from
uh El Camino and um so I thought it was
funny whenever they did the uh they
decided to use this scene because it had
the beanies built in right there for
them
and I thought it worked pretty well I
mean obviously
uh you know Aaron Paul is at a different
point in his life than Jesse was but
it all worked for me Richard
janvren thank you for the five I think
the Kim lawyer teaser was in reference
to her eventually disavowing her license
knows something later in my opinion also
spoiler marioness huel
yeah the I think that you know one of
the one of the most popular theories
about that
was that it would be her that that her
reading the oath was be would be a
flashback to when she first did it
so that's still a good idea even if
that's what they were trying to evoke
you know what I mean
um I don't think that that means that we
won't see it again but if we didn't I
wouldn't feel like that was you know a
big deal
Serpentine thank you for the 10. these
are the best two shows on TV when it's
over I will probably spend the next few
years
re-watching this universe over and over
and over like a psychopath thank you
guys for the great commentary well thank
you for watching and I agree they are
great shows absolutely
slup photography thank you for the five
have we seen anything to do with those
diamonds yet I don't believe we have
what do you guys think will come of
those love all your videos
um I think that they were you know a way
to show that he that in that little box
you know they're a way to show inside
that little box that he's he did have he
wasn't broke you know
um and I think
you know we were kind of talking about
this earlier if the origin story will be
important or not
I think it was just a visual way to show
us that you know he has something to
fall back on
they could come into play I mean they
were pretty conspicuously you know shown
there and so
um we'll just have to wait and see on
that
M thank you for 10 through the 10 Gene
might find the cancer guy very ill due
to the barbiturates combined with his
meds decide to save his life unlike what
Walt did with Jesse's girlfriend and
redeem himself a bit that way
it would be an interesting situation we
kind of talked about this with another
question
um
you know it would it would be a point of
like what will he do will he make the
right choice because he's clearly
breaking the law
and he's living under assumed identity I
mean really the right logical choice
would be for him to leave the guy there
and and not deal with it so um
it could be an interesting situation but
we'll have to wait and see
pmcc thank you for the three dollars
maybe Gene confesses to the cancer guy
or Marion
um
confesses
yeah I don't know like I you know like I
said I thought that there was motivation
because of a large uh uh reward before
for people to maybe turn him in
you know where he can maybe use that to
help somebody you know say look I'm
going to turn myself in anyways why
don't you do it and you get this money
but um
I'm not sure about unburdening himself
you know like I don't know how far that
would go as far as
you know
resolving his issues we'll see William
thank you for the five Francesca is
being tapped entailed obviously obvious
that so is Kim did they ever divorce
Gene is upset she is cooperating and
gave up Ice Station Zebra
those things may all be true we don't
know about the divorce as far as I know
but I don't think that
the kind of upset he was
is about learning that she gave up
the sum of his money or something like
that because I just don't think that
stuff matters to him that much
um
Tom schnauz he said in Hollywood
Reporter about
um
about the money he's not doing this for
money at all he's doing this because
something about that phone call brought
up a lot of pain and hurt
and as we know from the past and all
that went down with Howard Hamlin and
Kim hiding the truth about Lalo and the
reasons why she did it and the breakup
that happened
it all caused a lot of pain that pushed
him into going full full Saul Goodman
so yeah that that's I would say
it's something
not you know it's not about the money
it's about something that caused him
pain and you know well we'll have to
wait and see what that was
Dylan kubett thank you for the 199 do
you think that we will get one more
major death
I I don't uh I don't think it would be I
don't think it's necessary I don't think
we could rule it out I mean Marion you
know the what what uh Courtney was
saying about Marion earlier
could come into play but
I'm not really expecting a death at this
point at this at this point Eli HG thank
you for the 279 Canadian the universe
pays no mind to what people deserve
sure uh but
at the end of season five whenever Peter
Gould was talking about how we should
look at the story that was the question
that he brought up what is this guy
Jimmy McGill deserve so that's why I
think we we look at it through that
um you know that way
hands Charlotte thank you for the two
dollars is Kim an associate in Saul
Goodman and Associates no I don't think
that was ever the case
they shared an office but they as much
as he wanted it to be Wexler McGill it
never happened and so I think no he she
now that she's gone and she
resigned from the bar she would not be
one of the associates
thank you for the two Marion equals his
end
karma for scamming old people in the
past yep
we brought that up and I think that that
would be Justice for Irene
that's what I I like to shout that out
whenever I hear that that part of the uh
whenever the conversation goes in that
direction Cloud thank you for the 4.99
Gene is gonna walk into the guy with
Cancer's house and see him taking meth
then give him legal advice now that
would be a Twist that would absolutely
be a twist
Gene takovic is not a bonded lawyer or a
uh you know he's not a practicing lawyer
either
there's a long scroll hold on I'm gonna
get something here we go big Ralph
another good fellow's reference thank
you for the 10 big Ralph when Francesca
told Jean she gave away all the tiger
fish money
why did you do that yep that is that is
that's another one you're right
yeah like I said I I saw that someone
had compiled a bunch of them I just
didn't get a chance to read it I just
sort of scrolled past it
but I do believe that there was yeah but
I like I was saying I do believe that it
was intentional and that there are more
HK thank you for the 199 got it with
cancer dies
and Gene gets in trouble
I I don't know I was thinking about this
and I think that
him waking up you know the the fact that
the barbiturates wore off I think that
there's there's a lot of potential
in in gene being stuck there and having
to to solve the problem to figure out
his way out you know that's a lot of
what
what things boil down to so that that's
kind of where I think it's going but if
he does die
I mean if he did die if he's dead when
he goes in there then he could just
leave that would actually be
you know that that wouldn't that
wouldn't there was nothing that would
tie him to that yet so I don't know
we'll see
chandrika sanwal thank you for the five
final Mark equals final hurray
Gene wants to get caught at this point
he has his way to commit suicide turn
himself in
in hopes that Kim shows up one last time
um
I don't know I mean I think you could
say I think you could make an argument
that he subconsciously
is doing things that could in a reckless
way that could lead to him getting
caught
and he doesn't care I don't know that
that equates to him
wanting to get caught
you know what I mean like if his actions
are leading to that
I feel like there's a bit of his actions
you know
I don't think it's com I don't think
it's complete I think it's compulsive
and I think it's sloppy in that way but
I don't know that that he wants to get
caught and
how that that would make Kim show up
necessarily it all depends on the phone
call doesn't it thanks for that uh Oscar
Lopez thank you for the two dollars
increasingly static intro foreshadow
Gene downfall
I I'm sure that it would look like that
after the fact if that's what happens
um
but as of right this minute I can't say
for sure
I like the idea
but I mean that's sort of the that's
sort of been the idea the whole time
that the tapes are degrading and uh
I think what's interesting about that
now is the idea of that of them turning
on the record you know is it is it the
idea that you could you can you could
change you know you could rewrite the
story you could rewrite the ending I
think that that's what what stands out
to me the most about it JG thank you for
the thanks for the five seems like the
show is winding down towards a sad
tragic ending and not building to a
climactic exciting one
it certainly does feel that way
the question is is that
an indication of where we're going or is
that a setup for
you know for him to be able to turn it
around
dawn of Earth thank you for the 10.
we've yet to see Jimmy come up with a
scheme without the most precise planning
no chance he's just being reckless in a
desperate attempt to get his old life
back
he's got something up his sleeve
um
okay I I don't necessarily agree but I
see where you're coming from I
understand the argument that you're
making
we'll have to wait and see I I really do
feel like
um
you know that that what we saw at the
end of that was compulsive you know
compulsion
almost uncontrollable
but I could be wrong
Steve Bob JD thank you for the 9.99 I
got in here late do you have any big
predictions for Water Works that I
missed if not or if it's too much to
rehash it's okay just showing my support
well thank you for that Steve Bob
um
my initial thing was that when I heard
sprinkler's store that it was going to
be you know a dual meaning obviously but
part of that would be about Kim
and her coming back you know seeing her
seeing some scenes with her
especially seeing what she says on the
other side of that phone call
you know seeing that from her
perspective
frog thank you for the two what if Lyle
is Jeff's dad
um what if
what if
I just saw that there was someone
impersonating me yeah there you go pet
peppers
annoyed they spoiled the Walton Jesse
appearances
uh you know
I think that there was a I think that it
seemed pretty inevitable
and it's not a big surprise when you
think about it
um I mean there might have been a chance
that that could have been like think
about the way that the the episode
progression played out they jumped to
2005 to 2007 at the end of nine
so like how how do you feel like you
would think I mean how would you how
would you not think that Walt and and uh
Jesse were going to show up from that
point
I mean I kind of get it
pep uh but not
I don't think it's that big of a deal
agent Neptune thank you for the
five dollars Jean's time has expired no
more quarters for Kim I like that
B thank you for the five What official
crimes is genes Gene one and four now
I think it would be Rico stuff I think
conspiracy obviously
um
based on what
you know Francesca told him they
undercovered a lot of his uh his
corporations and the things he was using
for money money laundering so I'm
assuming that there's Paper Trails there
Steve Mueller thank you for the 4.99
prediction final episode is Through The
Eyes of Kim
possible
you know they did
re-contextualize things uh you know the
the kidnapping through
Jimmy's
um
perspective they could do that again one
more time with Kim
I hope they get right to it I hope they
don't hold it off but you know whatever
makes the most sense it's not a bad it's
not a bad prediction
Milo thank you for the nt-30 Deep fake
the earlier mall scene with the new Jeff
it's not something I would need to have
happen
um
maybe in the uh maybe people are
watching that down their line on on DVD
but uh I I don't think I don't think
it's not that big of a
you know that happened it's something
that happens sometimes characters get
recast
um
you know if you watch Game of Thrones
you remember there was a couple big ones
in that and um it didn't really didn't
really ruin the story
maybe other things dead but it wasn't
that ADHD whiskey thank you for the five
thoughts on Kim moving back to
Albuquerque buying the Saul Goodman
office and becoming the new criminal
lawyer of New Mexico
well after the last episode I like to
think that bill Oakley's filling that
void but
um I don't really see that I mean she
she walked away uh if she wants to go
back to being a lawyer
I think that she would probably do it
somewhere else rather than come back to
Albuquerque she doesn't really have
Roots there in the way you know uh
there's mostly just bad stuff when you
think about what happened for her there
so
I don't know we'll see I just I don't
think it's very likely
and it looks like I've made it to the
end if you have any more questions now
would be the time to get them out there
because I'm coming up on
three hours and uh I'm definitely going
to be getting out of here so
this is your last chance
and
all right so I'm gonna I'm not seeing
any more
are we super chatting until 8 A.M
um
Let's uh let's see if there's no more
then we're gonna be going to exactly
right now
so yeah thanks for coming out guys
thanks for all the questions thank you
to the moderators
um
that looked like things went pretty good
in there so I really appreciate it
oh wait here we go now that now that I'm
now I'm getting them
um
jerkaris [ __ ] thank you for the 199
again what's your favorite scam of all
time I feel like we did this last time
and it's it's pretty hard
um
just because I was re-watching the the
some of the earlier ones I I really like
the way that the one the way that they
handled the way that the first
um I mean it's not the most complex or
most interesting but I really like the
way that
Giselle jumps in in their Ken wins one
you know what I mean
and I just wanted to mention Joker's
[ __ ] I did see your message on Twitter
and I will
probably reach out to you at some point
to respond to that but I just hadn't had
a chance to do it yet
but yeah I don't know I mean all of them
are good like
that's one of the things that this show
does fantastically is it it
they really come up with some great
ideas for the scams
Trish D thank you for the five I
appreciate it
oh yeah Scott uh thanks for putting that
link and I was just trying to to fetch
my link to your Channel
and yeah Scott has he has a channel he
he uh he volunteered to help out and
moderate so do check that out
and that's gonna be it for me
I thank you guys for showing up
we'll be doing again next week I think
I'll try to come back on Saturday again
uh last week you know that was kind of
unfortunate
I was planning on it but it didn't
happen
I'm gonna try to make it happen this
week but I do I also have some other
videos I want to get out and um those
are kind of taking precedence right now
so
thanks for watching